telling him to go we understand that
resignation statement is being prepared
in number 10 as we speak and we expect
that the Prime Minister will deliver it
today what happens after that the prime
minister is expected by convention to
stay on while the conservative party
hold a leadership contest so we would
expect the prime minister to stay in
post while the cons while conservative
MPS vote for candidates and then
conservative members choose a candidate
so potentially two or three months he
will be imposed but we expect the Prime
Minister now to announce his resignation
today telling me within the last few
moments it's done it's over he's going
and I think we very much expect that is
what is going to happen the Prime
Minister has taken a long time to come
to this realization some deeply surreal
scenes last night Kay when we heard that
Michael Gove had been sacked from the
cabinet and we saw a government Minister
on Sky News Tim Lawton saying when
Michael Gove went to see him with the
whiskey and the revolver he drank the
whiskey and turned the revolver on
Michael Gove when you see conservatives
saying these kind of things on
television you know that the end is nigh
and now it seems the Prime Minister has
heard that message loud and clear not
least from his brand new Chancellor our
political editor Beth Rigby joining us
now about a significant moment when the
chancellor says to the Prime Minister go
he still doesn't go he then makes what
he said to him public and the prime
minister is going to go today is what
you understand
yeah we understand that the Prime
Minister will resign today look I spoke
to a cabinet minister this morning who
had seen the Prime Minister had a long
conversation with him yesterday and said
to the Prime Minister the game is up you
simply do not have the numbers to fill
posts in your government the country
will be ungovernable you cannot carry on
he tried to hold on last night you saw
the reports uh on the news but as we
understand it this morning let me just
get the statement up from on my phone
that Boris Johnson we understand has
spoken to the Tory uh party chair or
committee chair 22 chair Graham Brady
and agreed to stand down so we're going
to expect a resignation for from Boris
Johnson later today it's over for him he
tried until the very end to hold on but
when you're faced with over 50
government resignations half a dozen of
your cabinet walking out and finding
yourself unable to fill even cabinet
positions with ministers I'm willing to
be promoted with parliamentarians I'm
willing to serve that's when your
government collapses the game is up for
Boris Johnson he's going to have to
stand down
okay Beth so what happens now
unprecedented times the helicopters are
already up the street has gone
absolutely Bonkers what happens tonight
well what we will expect to happen now
is the prime minister will be in there
this morning he will be with his
advisors he will be drafting a
resignation statement and will expect to
hear from him later that will then of
course trigger a leadership race within
the conservative party and I think what
is difficult about this one compared to
the moment that Theresa May resigned in
2019 was back in 2019 there was a clear
successor to tree's mate was Boris
Johnson and he went on to win that
leadership race and a runoff against
Jeremy Hunt but this time the field is
wide open
politicians are not
oustin Boris Johnson because of a policy
policy disagreement as they did over May
regarding brexit and they don't really
have a plan of what comes next or who
they would like to be leader they are
literally ousting him because they
cannot serve under him and it's just got
too bad being in a Boris Johnson and
Cabinet Government and even
parliamentary party and so what will
happen now is he will resign and then
there will be a leadership contest and
in the coming days we will see all the
runners and riders coming out to make
their pitch to the Parliamentary party
we've already had overnight swella
bravaman she's the Attorney General the
most senior legal mind in government she
has announced overnight that she would
like to run we've got Rishi sunak we've
got Sajid Javid we've got Tom tugenhart
the chair of the Foreign Affairs select
committee who is perhaps the favored
choice of the one nation group of
conservatives in the party what about
Brandon Lewis the Northern Ireland
secretary that just resigned Nadeem
zahari Penny Morden I have got such a
long list of would-be Runners and Riders
and then we're going to have a
competition to see who takes the job but
it comes at a such a difficult time for
taught the country given the cost of
living crisis and the difficulties that
households up and down the land have are
having and I've just got an official
number 10 statement just out the Prime
Minister will make a statement to the
country today so Boris Johnson will make
a statement today it is over for him he
won the biggest majority didn't he back
in 2019 of any conservative prime
minister since Margaret Thatcher he was
potentially a two-term president prime
minister but after two and a half years
his Reign has come to an end and Boris
Johnson is standing down as conservative
party leader and prime minister
well it's the moment in history again
Beth isn't it you've witnessed so many
for as already as our political editor
um
when do you think we will hear from him
when will he make that statement and in
what capacity do we know yet I don't
know yet Kay uh what I do know is as
I've said there is now an official
statement uh saying that Boris Johnson
will make a statement to the country
later and as I was saying earlier he has
spoken to Sir Graham Brady who went to
see him yesterday the chair of the 22
Back bench committee and agreed to stand
down as a party leader so a new leader
can be in place by Party Conference so
that is in October at the end of
September into October a new party
leader in place for the Autumn sign of
um he will remain prime minister until
that point so I've just been told by a
number 10 figure the prime minister is
now agreeing to an orderly Handover of
power so instead of fighting on he's now
agreed to resign he's told grown Brady
of his intentions and he will remain
prime minister over the summer while
that leadership race is played out and
they hope to have a new prime minister
and conservative party leader by the
Autumn so the summer recess is going to
be taken up by a lot of campaigning by
would-be new Prime Ministers and
conservative party leaders it is such an
incredible moment we could see really as
I was saying a couple of days ago that
his time was up when those resignations
happened in cabinet that was perhaps the
moment and then the snowballing effect
over the 12 hours following when dozens
of Governor resignations began to fall
in and cabinet members then went didn't
they yesterday in a delegation to tell
Boris Johnson he had to go but even last
night number 10 were briefing of his
Defiance telling me that he was going to
call Sir gray and Brady's Bluff that he
was going to force a confidence vote in
him well overnight and as Dawn broke and
more people resigned Brandon Lewis
standing down as Northern Ireland
secretary and then Nadim zahawi telling
the Prime Minister that he had to go and
then we had Michelle Donnell and also
the education secretary the game up for
Boris Johnson however hard he fought
however much he wanted it it was simply
not tenable for him to continue
but Beth he's caused an awful lot of
angst in the process hasn't he it's I
mean everybody keeps oh not everybody
several people keep telling me how
dignified he is as prime minister we
haven't seen much dignity over the last
48 hours
look he is a politician as I said in my
report last night that defies political
Gravity the conventions he believes
doesn't apply to him he thinks he can do
things differently and that spirit in a
way is what drove him into brexit and
then drove him into that 2019 election
and did well for him he won a huge
majority he was the most successful
conservative leader since Margaret
Thatcher but some of his flaws his
character flaws uh his conduct his
self-goals own goals really are the
things that brought him down and in the
end as hard as he may fight if your
government is collapsing you cannot run
a country and if you cannot run a
country however much he might want it he
cannot remain as prime minister okay
what what might we expect later look
it's all very fluid but normally what
would happen if the Prime Minister would
come out of the door at 10 down in
Street like you can see it on your
screen there at the Flint comes out and
they make a statement to the world's
media and the country outside Downing
Street announcing that they intend to
stand down so now the race to replace
Boris Johnson is on
okay so Beth
uh let me just recap just
from away you can see it on your screen
in the last few minutes we've heard that
Boris Johnson has agreed to an orderly
transition after agreeing to step down
as conservative party leader Ergo prime
minister he's going and he is going
today Beth is with us our political
editor of course so Beth just run us
through what's going to happen next with
people just tuning our way here on the
breakfast show
okay so what's happened in the past
couple of hours is that there have been
further cabinet resignations than Boris
Johnson has now agreed that he cannot
continue as prime minister uh that he
will step down that he will make a
statement to the country today and that
he will remain as prime minister until
uh there is a successor and the
conservative party hope to have a new
party leader and a new prime minister a
bi-party conference at the beginning of
October what will happen now is the
prime minister as I saying will be
inside number 10 with his top team and
he will be preparing the words that he
wants to deliver to the country I would
imagine that he would like to take that
moment to talk to people about his
successes about the referendum winning
that for the brexiteers and then about
delivering brexit against the odds about
his big electoral mandate one of the
reasons he was very reluctant to stand
down and defiant was from his
perspective he won a mandate from 14
million people across this country and
he believed that that mandate was bigger
than those in his party who would want
him gone so I imagine he would talk
about his success and then I imagine
that he will reflect on what has
happened and then talk about the future
and wish any successor while but it will
be such a hard statement for him to make
I was with him in Rwanda in Kigali on
the chogham the Commonwealth heads of
government Summit
a couple of weeks ago and and in that in
the in the huddles in the briefings he
gave to journalists he was a politician
that believed Not only would he win the
next election but he could still
potentially govern into the 2030s he did
not want want to leave number 10 and
actually what he will go down as in
history instead is one of the shortest
serving conservative Prime Ministers
there had been he had it didn't he in
his graphs to potentially serve for two
terms but it's over for him so he will
come out I imagine make a statement on
the steps of number 10 and then the page
turns and the focus will then be on all
the runners and Riders and who in the
conservative party will replace him
despite suggestions that people I think
I was reading the papers this morning
that that anybody that wanted to get rid
of them would have to bathe their hands
in blood in some Shakespearean way
before he could be dragged away from
number 10 but two of the people that
went to see him last night Brandon Lewis
or certainly he was a signatory to
trying to get rid of him last night
although he was trapped in Northern
Ireland in Belfast because his flight
was delayed and then also the treasure
the chancellor both of them this morning
have said the game is up
okay I I think it's very simple what
happened which was there was a prime
minister going to bed last night if he
even slept saying that he was going to
hang on and stand in and carry on but
the numbers are simply not there he had
no other option he can't run a
government or the country if he cannot
fill cabinet vacancies if he cannot get
other back benches to step up and to
serve and what will have happened is
those closest to him would have tapped
him on the shoulder and said Boris
Johnson as much as you may want to carry
on you simply can't and as I understand
it the cabinet ministers that had
conversations with him yesterday that
was exactly what they were telling him
now he didn't want to hear that in fact
he sacked Michael gave because Michael
gave was threatening to resign but when
Brandon Lewis sent that letter in this
morning when the chancellor that he has
just appointed them publicly tells him
to go he literally doesn't have a
cabinet and this is not a presidential
situation this is a parliamentary
democracy run by uh cabinet Collective
responsibility it's a parliamentary
democracy where you need the support of
your cabinet and you need the support of
enough of your parliamentary party to
remain as prime minister and that
whether he likes it or not is the
Mandate that they can take away from him
and he's obviously realized today that
even if he wants to carry on which I am
sure he does he simply cannot so he's
standing down and actually what's
interesting about what's emerging this
morning is there was some talk yesterday
about him fighting to the death about
there being chaos if he stands down but
he's now saying that he will stay on As
a caretaker prime minister until his
success is appointed
Beth I know you need to go and talk to
an awful lot of people you'll be with us
you've got a very busy day ahead of you
thanks so much indeed for breaking that
news with us here on the breakfast show
on sky this morning thank you okay so
here we go um where are you watching us
around the world you're joining the
breakfast show here on Sky News to the
news that Boris Johnson has agreed to
resign the Prime Minister will step down
he will make a statement to the country
today he will remain as prime minister
until there is a successor and the
conservative party hope to have a new pm
and a new party leader by the beginning
of their party Conference in October so
yeah it doesn't just happen straight
away he'll remain in post for now As a
caretaker prime minister if you will
Boris Johnson currently in Downey Street
preparing that resignation speech it
comes after 57 MPS resigned in the last
two days his chancellor who he only
appointed 36 hours ago this morning
telling him to go and go no it does
appear that that was The Tipping Point
for the Prime Minister he had nowhere
else to hide five other cabinet
ministers also stepping down as well so
this is playing out in real time the
Prime Minister said that he would have
to be dragged out of there with people
with their hands covered in blood in
some theatrical Shakespearean manner
that's not happening later on today the
podium will come out of number 10 down
the street the Prime Minister will stand
behind it no Daddy will tell us about
some of his achievements as betrayed he
was saying but however the way you coat
it he is going he is leaving the role as
prime minister tomorrow
okay we are witnessing a moment of
History Boris Johnson the Prime Minister
who won this historic majority two and a
half years ago is now being forced to
resign because of an exodus of his own
ministers including in the cabinet he
yesterday was determined to Brazen it
out to carry on somehow or other it has
now been made abundantly clear to him
even by his closest supporters that the
party will not accept him staying on and
many MPS are doing this because they
believe they're voters do not want him
to stay on so Boris Johnson the most
electorally successful leader since
Margaret Thatcher in 1987 is now on his
way out is it conservative party is now
on his way out and that will be
happening he's been confirmed today he
is in there right now writing his
resignation statement and we will no
doubt see at some point in the coming
hours a lectern coming out and Boris
Johnson delivering his final thoughts on
what he's achieved I'm sure we'll hear
about getting brexit done about leveling
up and
and what he has left what is left for
his successor he will remain as prime
minister until October while a
leadership contest plays out of the
beauty contest will no doubt start
pretty soon but his time in office is
coming to an end and his supporters will
see this as something of a Greek tragedy
really that someone with so much
potential with that huge majority to do
whatever he wanted is now seeing his
time in office and in what can only be
described as a rather humiliating
fashion of unprecedented resignations
forcing him to the exit door I wish I
could share with you uh what's uh what's
happening here at the moment film Crews
coming all the time piling in all the
time from right around the world because
it is a momentous moment the prime
minister is about to come out well we're
not quite sure when but sometime within
the next couple of hours or so we'll be
coming out of that door and telling us
that finally the game is up what was it
that did for him what did for him was
the fact that even his closest allies in
cabinet told him they could not he could
not carry on they would not carry on
with him in post we've seen all these
resignations it began Tuesday night with
saja Javid and Rishi sunat resigning
within 10 minutes of each other it's
continued yesterday with the junior
ranks leaving their posts and then today
the Northern Ireland secretary the
wealth secretary and then those who have
to stay in their posts like pretty Patel
and Ben Wallace because of the national
security reasons you cannot leave the
person in charge of our security
services the person in charge of our
Armed Forces they cannot leave their
positions unmanned they've both made
clear Ben Wallace personally [ __ ] Patel
through allies I've spoken to that they
would do if they could but they the
messages to the Prime Minister we have
to stay in post but you no longer can
continue and of course the final blow
came from this brand new chance Leonard
Dean zahawi who had appeared 24 hours
ago thought prime minister could turn
this around he has now said publicly
that Boris Johnson cannot turn this
around and must go so an exodus of his
senior ministers I mean yesterday we
knew that some of them were in here
telling him it was over Michael Gove got
sacked for doing that so when we talk
about how this is ending compared to
previous Prime Ministers Margaret
Thatcher had what's been described as
the men in Gray suits coming to tell her
the game was up Theresa May had gray and
Brady tell her the game was up Boris
Johnson had men and women coming to tell
him it was over but he clung on and it
is only now when all the resignations
have reached such a pitch that is really
not possible for him to carry on
governing country now we now know that
he believes his time in office is over
for Walden's with us he was the former
press secretary at two Boris Johnson has
worked with him very closely for a
number of years
um hi good morning were you expecting
this this morning hello kay uh I should
have said to you on many occasions in
recent months and I wrote In The Times
overnight Boris doesn't do change he
doesn't do apology and he pretty much
doesn't do resignation unless it
benefits him and I was getting very
worried this morning that that he was
actually not only trashing his legacy
but trashing the very tenets of
democracy so all I can say to you this
morning Kay is thank God you know he has
finally done the right thing but what a
fast to be dragged kicking and screaming
like he is is an embarrassment and and
what I hope now I mean here's the
situation right is he going to reappoint
the 57 ministers and trade envoys and
pps's as he goes on for them this is all
totally unnecessary the writing was on
the wall and I presume he is going to
have to reappoint people to cabinet and
not give new jobs to people and that
would be the right thing to do and I do
hope when we see the Prime Minister
later that instead of the usual Guff
because that's what it's become I'm
sorry to say you know as an old friend
he knows my views on it on it all it has
become that let's not have all the usual
pandering Boris let's have a serious
sober statement that the right
conclusion has been reached that he can
salvage some of the Legacy around brexit
and around Ukraine and around covid
vaccine yes let's give him that right
but let's also have an orderly
transition and that means making sure
that we don't have useless pointless
legislation on the agenda but they only
concentrate on things that really matter
the stuff like solving the the current
cost of living crisis and then we have a
sober Handover what we saw last night
was beyond fast you know dipping hands
in blood the the revenge stuff on
Michael gave pathetic
absolutely pathetic I'm sorry to say and
he is now finally seen that the writing
arm is not on the wall but it has taken
the resignation of his education
secretary who must be the shortest
serving cabinet minister in history
um and and his new Chancellor telling
him the game is up and I think he's come
dangerously close to reaching a point
where he would trash his entire Legacy
he has an opportunity to today now
having resigned to do the right thing in
terms of this speech and the right thing
over the next six to 12 weeks and I hope
he takes that opportunity and I hope he
does it properly because that is what
will Define him going forward
okay and as far as what's going on
behind us in number 10 at the moment two
questions what will be happening he'll
be surrounding him and how will he be
feeling
well I I suspect you'll be feeling
utterly miserable
um but it's self-inflicted from the very
beginning this has been self-inflated
he's made missteps all along in the
handling of these incidents and
ultimately it has cost him and the talk
yesterday of I carry on I have a mandate
you know he doesn't have a mandate he
certainly doesn't have a mandate now but
he doesn't anyway he's lost
made a little accidental misstep earlier
where she referred to two-term
presidents and then corrected himself
and that's the problem I think Boris has
seen this as a presidency he has taken
his example from the mayorality with no
opposition and come into number 10 with
the same presidential plan and that has
cost him so what will be going on now is
that they'll be you know presumably I
mean it could be that you know he he'll
he'll feel very disappointed but
actually Prime Ministers when they make
the decision there's there's a huge
weight that immediately comes off their
shoulders and it could be that they're
all sitting around you know probably
watching us throwing things at me
um you know um just saying oh well you
know it was great and talking about
their greatest hits
um I hope that their somberly and savory
preparing for the next 12 weeks writing
a decent principle of resignation speech
and he should be given credit for you
know for for a lot of stuff that's
happened but if you're going to be prime
minister it's a massively difficult job
and you've got to get much of it right
and when you get it wrong you've got to
be brave enough to front up and say that
and I hope that he does some of that
today and I I hope that you know that
when we hear the speech and when we hear
the plan for the next 12 weeks we have a
somber assessment of the Grave problems
that face this country the grave
problems that face Europe and the world
with everything that's going on in
Ukraine and the like
um and and that we have 12 weeks of calm
where the Prime Minister can salvage
some of this Legacy and we can have an
orderly transition to a new prime
minister and a new government
yes he can you know he's I mean it
sounds like he's still kicking and
screaming and didn't want to go but
they've persuaded him that and I'm glad
they have and I hope that people like
guitar Harry and David canzenia are
close to him have stood up to him this
morning and said you know I hope that's
what's happened that it's over and they
now help him through this this next
period and he is absolutely capable of
that you know I I've said to you many
times okay he is not a bad man right but
it has unraveled and it is over and he
needs to think soberly about the country
and yes about his legacy and actually
his legacy will be vastly improved if he
deals with the next six to 12 weeks
correctly it is the next test in Boris
Johnson's extraordinary career and I
hope he reflects on that in the next few
hours and does the right thing
how do you think you'll be remembered
well I think if he was still here next
Tuesday and what he'd done this morning
and they booted him out I think he'd be
remembered for only this frankly I think
he's just about been able to pull it
back and I think the interesting thing
is if he was booted out next week as
opposed to now and going as he has I
suspect they wouldn't have allowed him
to continue as prime minister he would
have had an interim prime minister and
that would have been an extraordinary
event so I I think he will be remembered
as a great communicator
um you know you know the man that you
know absolutely delivered brexit and got
brexit done
um you know I think history tends to
judge Prime Ministers better you know
you know with the benefit of hindsight
um you know and he's done the right
things
um uh around Ukraine but I think he will
also remember somebody that that
fundamentally didn't listen and that
became somewhat presidential
um and I think that that's the reason
that he's in the pickle and has had to
resign
um you know there's great things ahead
I'm sure for for Boris Johnson he has
great things to offer I just hope that
he can offer them in a sober sensible
and and pragmatic way uh you know and
look he's the greatest campaigner of his
generation and he'll always be able to
say my party got a 80 seat majority and
a massive mandate uh unfortunately I
suspect that not much of that will be
remembered now because of the events of
the last week
Phil Walton it's always fascinating to
talk to you thanks very much indeed
um very close to the Prime Minister
former press secretary uh giving us an
insight into the mind of the man who
will be stepping down as prime minister
later on today we've heard from the man
who would be prime minister Kia Stormer
leader of the labor party of course he
said it is good news for the country
that Boris Johnson has resigned as prime
minister but it should have happened
long ago he will always be unfit for
offers he has been responsible for lies
Scandal and fraud on an industrial scale
and all those who have been complicit
should be utterly ashamed the Tory party
have inflicted chaos upon the country
during the worst case of living crisis
in decades and they cannot now pretend
they are the ones to sort it out they
have been in power for 12 years the
damage they have done is profound 12
years of economic stagnation he says 12
years of declining Public Services 12
years of empty promises enough is enough
we don't need to change the Tory at the
top we need a proper change of
government we need a fresh start for
Britain my old buddy and Sky news
commentator Adam and contributor Adam
Bolton is with us now hey Adam
hello okay I wouldn't want to miss a day
like this without speaking to you
we've done quite a few of these what
does this rank
I think this is the most spectacular
ever I think comparatively the
departures from Office of uh Mrs
Thatcher uh or uh Tony Blair or Theresa
May were relatively orderly uh the
difference this time is that the
incumbent the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson has been trying with all his
might to resist uh the due process of
what happens to a prime minister uh when
their own party can no longer report
them and we've had the frankly trumpian
claims uh repeatedly from Mr Johnson and
his camp that he somehow has a personal
Mandate of 14 million votes to stay in
office and I think we should be in no
doubt that this has been messy uh Mr
Johnson hasn't been sitting in Downing
Street planning a graceful exit he's
been fighting tooth and nail to stay in
and now he's simply been overwhelmed by
the resignations of ministers and also
the mood of his own party uh clear I
think that had he fought it as he was
intending to a second vote of confidence
next week he would have lost it so he's
going now and I think because of that K
I wouldn't be as certain as will Walden
that we're going to see a kind of uh
12-week uh president sort of
um Shadow prime minister ship where
Boris Johnson is going to do a victory
tour there's a lot of voices within the
conservative party saying much better
that he should go now and that Dominic
Robb the Deputy Prime Minister should be
the stand-in for the transition simply
because uh Boris Johnson has created so
much chaos bought British politics and
the conservative party and the
government into so much so much ill
repute that there is not a mood that I'm
picking up from senior conservatives to
allow him a kind of Victory lap at the
end of his Premiership and that is quite
significant because if he were to go now
he would have served for less time than
Theresa May uh for who he was her
Nemesis of course uh because they're
about 28 days longer that she had an
office as of today whereas if he is
allowed a caretaker Premiership up until
October uh he will overtake Theresa May
so I suspect one of the reasons uh why
uh we're not hearing a clear message as
yet from Boris Johnson is because that
fight is still going on within the
conservative party and there aren't
clear rules on that
or can they say no not you're going now
I think he can certainly try and stay
but I think constitutionally it is
within the power of the conservative
party and the conservative MPS to Simply
remove him as leader so uh you know it's
another mess frankly which we're seeing
but certainly uh we're seeing uh
journalists who from The Spectator crowd
who are close uh to uh Boris Johnson and
his Camp tweeting that there is
considerable argument going on at the
top I mean of course one of the effects
I think if Dominic Robb were to step in
as caretaker while a new Tory leader is
chosen is that he himself would probably
pretty much have to rule out of running
for the leadership and we don't know
what his intentions are but he may not
want to give that up
um it's often said that he who or she
the person that Wheels the knife the
sword does not wear the crown
um and people use that as an example to
point to Rishi sunak who uh was one of
the first to go him and of course that
he Javid as well
um but that's not always the case is it
I mean we've been talking recently Adam
have we nod about people like Gordon
Brown who did that to uh Tony Blair and
there are many other examples within the
conservative party as well where those
that have wielded the knife have still
won the crowd yeah well Boris Boris
Johnson uh of course wielded the knife
against Theresa May and he ended up as
uh we all know prime minister but I
think the point in this case Kay if I
can use another analogy is that this has
turned into
murder on the Orient Express
because of of uh Boris Johnson's
resistance everybody now does have their
hands dipped in blood I mean even people
like pretty Patel swella bravaman Nadim
zahawi uh people who uh continue to work
uh under Boris Johnson have all said
that he should go so I don't think it
will be possible to pick out uh the
former Chancellor as the person who
wielded the knife I mean in a certain
sense if anybody wielded the knife
they're two people uh one is Chris
pincher because of his alleged appalling
behavior and sexual harassment at a time
when he must have known uh that the
Prime Minister was extremely vulnerable
to any allegations of impropriety and
secondly we shouldn't forget forget Sir
Simon McDonald
who basically produced chapter and verse
showing that Boris Johnson was lying and
sending other ministers out to lie on
his behalf over what he knew about
Pinscher those are the two things that
have happened this week that have forced
him out uh compared to the vote of
confidence on June 6th
uh just uh seeing a tweet from Ed Davey
Adam uh sir Ed Davey I should say leader
of the liberal Democrat saying the idea
that the conservatives might make Boris
Johnson caretaker for anything is
frankly ludicrous is what he says the
man's never taken care of anything in
his life so there will be some
resistance for him to be the caretaker
over the summer yes I think there will
be and frankly there's also going to be
reputational management for the
conservative party that do they want to
inflict Boris Johnson after his behavior
on the nation for a further three months
I suspect they don't because they look
at the opinion polls they can see that
they're behind labor and to have Boris
Johnson
with any levers Within Reach after his
behavior will be something that will
concern the conservative party and we'll
also probably concern the government and
the Civil Service I mean I think what we
are going to see in this process whoever
emerges as conservative party leader is
a pretty Mass clear out of those people
who have been acolytes of Boris Johnson
in the government quite possibly going
as far as Simon case the cabinet
secretary on the one hand and a very
prominent members of the present cabinet
I think most of them out like Boris
Johnson they will find that time will be
up under the new leader
resignation speech from him today maybe
as early as this morning we'll have to
wait and see our political editor Beth
Rigby will be updating us on that in
just a moment then whom do you think
well a fascinating thing about this and
I've been saying and writing about this
for a while is that conservative
leadership contests tend to be sparked
about getting rid of someone when the
party doesn't necessarily know who's
going to emerge at the end of now an
election process and I can think of
perhaps a dozen MPS who could end up
leading the party as Prime Ministers I
mean remember no one saw John Major
coming when Mrs Thatcher was forced out
no one particularly saw that in Duncan
Smith was going to emerge as leader of
the conservative party and leader of the
opposition and so you know one looks at
the favorites and obviously one can see
people like the child the former
Chancellor uh Rishi sunak for example
one can see ambitious members of the uh
present government like Liz truss I mean
you can see The Bookies odds but you can
look at people who perhaps people plant
talking about I mean pretty Patel for
example she was close to Boris Johnson
but turned against him we understand
Zoella bravaman similar position she's
now putting herself forward a lot of
people have been talking to me about
Penny Morton who had an impressive stint
as defense secretary but was then
demoted by Boris Johnson because she
wasn't one of his personal supporters so
that I mean I'm not saying any of them
are going to do it but I'm saying the
way this process works with MPS
whittling down a short list of two and
then the party membership in the country
uh taking place in a ballot to choose
one of those two it is very very
difficult to predict who will emerge at
the end of it and I think the bitterness
and Rancor that we've seen this week and
the stances which individual politicians
have taken towards getting rid of Boris
Johnson will definitely color how people
choose to vote I mean it's interesting
for example that we've heard this
morning that Steve Baker the leader of
the ERG says that he's getting a lot of
requests to stand and it has to be said
that as a right-winger someone who was a
strong supporter of brexit he was one of
the very early people to say that Boris
is Johnson's Behavior as prime minister
was unacceptable and he should go now
that may count in his favor but
correspondingly it may count against him
with some people who feel sore about the
departure of Boris Johnson
just Adam coming from Facts now on
Twitter the first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon there will be a widespread
sense of relief that the chaos of the
last few days indeed months will come to
an end though the notion of Boris
Johnson staying on us PM until the
Autumn seems far from ideal and surely
not sustainable so even if the party
feel that they can keep him on as prime
minister during the summer they're now
lining up from the opposition parties to
say absolutely not controversy even when
he said he's going
exactly and as ever a mess we don't have
a clear uh sign from the Prime Minister
we understand we've been told he's going
but we're not being told how he sees uh
his departure going and I suspect that's
because argument is going on at this
very moment uh in those uh behind the
door behind you as to precisely the
nature of his departure I mean those
that famous quote from Macbeth nothing
so became him as the in his life as the
leaving of it uh and this is a political
life we're seeing at the end of I don't
think we've heard the loss of Boris
Johnson but the fact that it's a mess
bitter and rancorous uh and all about
Boris Johnson is entirely characteristic
of the political life of this man so far
uh okay Adam we're just looking at
Nicholas sturgeon uh there as uh her
tweet
um and uh joining me now is our
political editor Beth Rigby um Beth
where you go left and out
yeah look this was this was sort of the
beginning of the end really on Tuesday
night when Sajid Javid and Rishi sanat
resigned but the cabinet then showed
Boris Johnson up but then what happened
as you saw was over the following a few
hours they were just there was an
avalanche of resignations to the point
that the prime minister's still trying
to hang in there on uh last night he had
no option this morning to but to resign
Brandon Lewis go in he was unable to
fill cabinet positions and what's
clearly happened is the people around
him have said Boris Johnson it's time to
go so after two and a half years uh soon
he will be coming out here to make a
statement to the country do we know
about resigning I don't know sometime
maybe this morning don't know yet okay
um it comes to uh something when the the
chancellor tells you in private to go
you still stay and then he makes the
view public I think I think is that
James dodridge I think
yes James dodridge has the Prime
Minister done the right thing sir good
morning sir are you sorry to see him go
sir
are you sorry to see him go sir
it's okay that that's James Doddridge he
is the prime minister's ministerial aide
so he's the guy that goes into the
commons and he talks to all of the MPS
and he was the one that spoke to our
John Craig last night doing a public
statement saying there was going to be a
speech on the economy and the mood was
buoyant in number 10 and the Prime
Minister was going to go on so he's
obviously gone in there now to talk uh
to his boss to talk to him about that
resignation statement but where were we
so we expect him to come out now but
you're right there's already some
controversy around Boris Johnson's
statement this morning or a statement
rather from uh number 10 saying that he
intends to stay on until a new
conservative party leader is elected a
biparty conference at the beginning of
October uh George Freeman a minister who
resigned this morning uh said has just
said the PM's now finally done the
decent thing and he needs to hand in the
seals to the office and he also says he
needs to point a caretaker under who
ministers can serve so his view is that
there should be a caretaker prime
minister I've just checked that out with
a cabinet minister who is of the view
that the Prime Minister should be able
to stay until uh until a successor is
found is is elected or chosen rather by
the conservative party by the membership
so
so I'm just getting this through as well
this is from uh this is from my
colleague Sam coats he understands as we
were talking about there is some cabinet
concern about any attempt by Boris
Johnson if he tries to stay as late as
October uh one option they think is more
sexual this is from Sam could be to get
the last two uh in the summer Handover
in September or wrapped Rob romit Robb
takes over the Deputy Prime Minister As
a caretaker but as I said another
cabinet minister stepped in for him
several times
inspiration didn't he just uh a couple
of weeks ago the Prime Minister yeah but
I mean this is another cabinet minister
to me I said are you happy for him to
stay on As a caretaker prime minister
and he says only as Theresa May did he
holds the reins until a new leader is
chosen but that isn't kind of the moment
is it now what we're waiting for now is
Boris Johnson to come out and make that
statement he thought that he would be a
prime minister that would serve one to
perhaps even three terms he was joking
when we were in Kigali at welcome about
two weeks ago about the prospect of
being prime minister into the 2030s but
the mood of the party and now his
cabinet was you have to go okay the
ability for editor Beth Rigby with me
here in Downing Street if you are just
tuning our way you are watching Sky News
and as you can see on the bottom of your
screen there it is a pretty uh
blockbusting breaking news for you here
on sky this morning the breakfast show
you're very very welcome to join us it
is 10 o'clock welcome to dining Street
we start with that breaking news that
the Prime Minister Boris Johnson is to
resign today and we'll make a statement
right here in just a short while he's
expected to remain as prime minister
until there is a successor and the
conservative party hope to have a new pm
and a new party leader by the start of
Party Conference when's that well it's
in October can you believe it it comes
after 57 MPS resigned in the last 48
hours is chancellor who he appointed
only 36 hours ago telling him it's time
to go and go now Beth is with us so that
was the straw that broke the camel's
back I suppose the chancellor saying
it's over
I spoke to a cabinet minister that saw
the Prime Minister yesterday who told me
this morning I was coming in into
Downing Street that it was made very
clear to him last night by a number of
cabinet ministers that they held no
personal animosity to him they were they
didn't want to resign but he simply did
not have the numbers to fill the
government positions you know why you
know I did a report at half line last
night 38 resignations by this morning it
was 52. now it's 59. 59 I can't I can't
keep up exactly so 59 resignations he
hasn't got enough people in the
Parliamentary party willing to serve and
when you get to that point as a prime
minister you can't fill your cabinet
positions you can't fill a ministerial
pose you can't govern the country you
can't run a government you cannot carry
on and I think really there was a last
throw of the diet last dance to try and
hang on to Klingon last night but the
resignation I think of Brandon Lewis
Simon Hart the Welsh actually resigning
at 11 o'clock last night as well a Bravo
man the Attorney General coming out late
last night calling on him to go and then
Brandon Lewis letter this morning I mean
the writing was on the wall it was
interesting even pretty Patel who was
one of the prime minister's most loyal
uh supporters and campaigned for him as
mayor of London she helped lead his
leadership campaign she got the
brexiteers to a line behind him so she
was so key to him even she went in
yesterday and said to him you do not
command the support of the Parliamentary
party it's time to go the last person
that was willing to hear it clearly was
him but this morning he's woken up he's
actually got no other choice we saw the
chief whip actually go in
um just after seven o'clock and Tamara
Co and he was with me this morning
recognize then there was something
effort he must have made his mind up
overnight or it was made up for him well
I think what happened overnight was he
was trying to get cabinet ministers not
to resign he was offering them lots of
other jobs someone told me that Brandon
Lewis for example was offered a series
of different positions uh which he
didn't want to take and the chief would
have gone in there this morning and I
imagine the discussion this morning was
you can't fill your government positions
you're going to have to resign may I
share with you what Sadiq Khan is saying
he's the mayor of London the Prime
Minister previously mayor of London of
course he says this has been one of the
most shameful sagas in the history of
British politics Boris Johnson has
resided over a government defined by
lies sleaze and utter lack of Integrity
unlawful Behavior incompetence and a
damaging culture of impunity in public
office we've also heard from the first
Minister we've also heard from others as
well who are all saying that good that
he's going but he shouldn't be allowed
to stay in office until October what do
you think well look I'm I'm sort of
checking that out with other people
another former cabinet minister has just
said to me him being a caretaker is okay
he can show he can show respect for
constitutional Norms so I think there's
quite a division there they do need it
they do need a caretaker prime minister
I think that the I think the story now
will move very quickly to who will
replace him
um they need a caretaker government over
recess into September when they will
elect a new party leader I have so many
questions for you I'm going to go I mean
I I don't know I I I but I can't at the
moment I
there is obviously some concern and
opposition leaders of course will say
get out now because they would like to
create as much uh chaos if you like it's
been pretty Chelsea actually the first
few weeks but that they'll want to
create as much uh chaos and disruption
now as possible but you know my
cabinet's also the same to me this
morning anyway that they think it's okay
if he stays on and just holds the fort
let me ask you something else if I may
um to get the new prime minister in post
first of all it's up to the Tory MPS
they were quickly down to two yes and
then it goes to the country yes it goes
to the park yeah Tory party members
there we go thank you and then after
that
before that I'm getting all over the
place before that there could be eight
ten of them that want to be uh prime
minister that has to be whittled down
they have to do that between now and the
end of July otherwise it's not until the
Autumn because at the end of July that's
when they rise for the summer but the
house doesn't sit during the summer and
this this can they do it in that time so
these are all questions that we're going
to have to try and find out answer today
look as you said what happens now is
that the contenders uh make their pitch
and then they have a process where they
they launch their leadership bids and
then as you said there are a number of
rounds of voting from the Parliamentary
party not the public and the
Parliamentary party Whittle it down to
two contenders last time it was Jeremy
Hunt and Boris Johnson and then they go
around the country and try with a series
of hostels to try and convince
conservative party members to vote for
them and then it's whoever gets the most
votes wins but as you said now typically
uh the rounds of Tory party MPS voting
that can take
a few weeks sometimes it can take two
three four so they've also got to launch
all their leadership bids right so I'm
sure some of them are already working
but what I mean we've got all the press
conferences and the big moments of a
number of people launching their
leadership bids then they have to
whittle down and then they go to the
country so I can see that this process
might have to run but it will have to
run over recess but you're right in
terms of MPS voting it'd be difficult I
think I don't know how they're going to
make that happen before recess which is
meant to start on July I think it's the
20 21st okay so that is two and a half
weeks from now so it might be that
conservative MPS are voting on this
um
over the summer but look hey the other
thing is these things are unpredictable
do you remember uh when
um David Cameron resigned back in 2016.
Boris Johnson remember Boris Johnson was
meant to uh be uh in the race Michael
Gove then stabbed Boris Johnson in the
front they both eventually they both
they both pulled out of the race and
then there was this sort of curious
situation of a runoff potentially
between Andrew ledson and Theresa May
Andrew LED some then just was withdrew
and then Teresa
yeah but but Theresa May oh we've got a
little what is that
um so so basically do you remember
Theresa May then they she just got the
job so there wasn't a long process and
it happened very quickly I think this
time what's interesting is that the
field is wide open there isn't a plan B
it's not a parliamentary party have
ousted Boris Johnson because they want
to put a another in to his position or
change policy as it was with Boris
Johnson when he replaced Theresa may
they don't have a plan B they just don't
want him and that means it's a very wide
open race there will be a number of
people that want to replace him well I
mean there's so many where there's Rishi
sunak there's Sajid Javid clearly
Brandon Lewis might want to go Tom tug
and Hart who's the chair of the Foreign
Affairs select committee he'll fancy it
uh Penny mordant she is a brexiteer she
might uh want to do it who else have we
got I'm definitely missing Nadeem sahawi
Penny mordant uh might be the the cities
from Jeremy Hunt will he have another go
at it there's there's a number of them
that's when a brother man has already
said she would like to uh within cabinet
Dominic Raab might want to go at the
time
okay that's interesting so he ran last
time so he's ruled himself as Liz truss
who's not in the country actually she's
on a foreign secretary trip uh Steve
Baker or Steve Baker says that he's been
approached hasn't he so he might have a
go at it so you know we've already got
how many eight nine names now what will
happen is you have to get a number of
MPS uh to to support and then second you
and then you have to have enough MPS to
kind of make it serious bid so what will
happen is there will be some that would
like to that will have to drop out quite
quickly and then you'll quickly get into
a situation where you have five six
serious contenders and then they get
whittled down but they'll be on
television doing hostins and and all
sorts it's going to be really busy at a
time when Parliament is meant to be in
recess wait going to put your 50p who's
going to be the next prime minister I'm
not putting my 50 on but I can tell you
because I did look last night that in
terms of the The Bookies because I trust
them to make bets it actually Rishi
Rishi is actually I think he was 13 to
two but such a Javid also I think last
night was one or seven to one so you
know interesting that the two guys uh
that went fast are the Front Runners but
I I it honestly is wide open and and you
know Rishi sunak about a few weeks ago
was seen as a busted flush because the
controversy around his wife and on Dom's
status and the fact that he'd kept that
green card it felt like Rishi was over
but I think uh that Rishi sunak uh
probably still is a serious uh
proposition although many in the
conservative party don't really like his
position on the economy of course they
want more tax cuts but Richardson has to
be a city assortment still though as
well isn't it for the party you know
they wanted to get brexit done and if
you are a remainer I mean that's what
did for
um Jeremy Hunt potentially yeah it was
what did for Jeremy Hunt I mean really
Boris Johnson was nailed on in that that
race I mean Jeremy Hunt fought a good
fight uh but it really was won by 66 it
was really nailed uh really now done so
there's another just break in here Bim
aphalami also agrees that Boris Johnson
should stand down as leadership so he
was the vice chair of the party resigned
life on air on in the week so he agrees
that he doesn't want uh the Prime
Minister uh to be a kid when he resigns
is surrounded by Scandal prime minister
um I was just about to go to Samco so
I'm just being told he's not there so
what I'm going to do instead Beth is ask
you what will happen in the meantime to
all of those positions that have been
vacated because government can't run
they won't at the moment but they just
come back again I don't know if Boris
Johnson that's not impacting that's a
good question it might be that some of
those cabinets ministers that have
resigned go back into post for the time
being because now really the game is
over in terms of uh in terms of whether
or not Boris Johnson can carry on so it
might be that some of those uh cabinet
ministers decide to go back into post
and we'll ask them today and see what
they say but you know how many
resignations we had we've had the party
Cheryl of the Dowden went then we had
subject Javid then we had Rishi sanak
then we had uh Simon Hart uh Brandon
Lewis and Michael Gove was sacked so
that's fight that was I mean Oliver dad
was Professor that's five uh
vacant positions are in cabinet they
need filling they're massive jobs the
country needs to be run still but I
think the party now they've closed the
chapter on this controversy over Boris
Johnson and whether or not he can remain
prime minister I think they need to get
on now uh with trying to to put people
back into post and get on with Governors
have a quick drink of your tea uh
joining us in just a second will be the
uh justice Minister former Justice
Minister now conservative MP only that's
Mr cart play do you see with us now
he is with us now let's uh bring him in
should we hello to you thanks for
joining us uh on the program this
morning Mr Cartledge uh let me start by
what uh I finished off there with Beth
and that is would you be content to go
back into your job if Boris Johnson
stayed as uh interim prime minister over
the summer
well when you when you've only just
resigned that seems quite an
extraordinary question to consider as
you can appreciate
um I I don't even know what the
Constitutional propriety is as far as
I'm concerned I resigned this morning
um and I just have relief that
eventually the Prime Minister realized
the game was up and has now done the
right thing and hopefully we can now
move on
yeah it might be difficult to
contemplate but unless people like you
and others who have resigned the present
tally is 59. do go back to help run the
country then we're in um a very
difficult position my question to you is
would you be prepared to do that while
Boris Johnson was still in number 10.
I mean to be honest I'd have to wait and
and wait and begin and be called as it
were and if and if someone were to ask
me I'd obviously consider the time it
seems to me that that you know I I can't
sit here speculating whether that's
going to happen
um the immediate priority I think we've
achieved which is that you know given
his position was untenable the prime
minister's resigned
um obviously there's going to be a
frenetic amount of activity and next
week we'll be moving into leadership
election mode
it's not speculation though it's what
we're being told is going to happen the
Prime Minister has agreed we're being
told to stay in post until a new leader
is found uh will you understood but
obviously in terms of what he does what
happens in terms of ministerial
vacancies I mean that that would then
remain constitutionally a question for
him
yeah but he doesn't have enough
I may be wrong but I think you have to
have his list to General for example I
mean
um clearly you have to have a chance to
exchecker one assumes
um but I mean he if if he is staying in
the world of prime minister presumably
that will be his immediate task
um you know obviously it feels odd to
speculate on this when you've just
resigned but you know we'll want to get
the call then um you'd have to obviously
think about it but you can appreciate it
it's a big deal to resign and when you
do so you don't normally do it expecting
that you might be back in like a sort of
boomerang
yeah I don't know if you've seen what
the leader of the opposition has been
saying uh this morning he says it's it's
a good job he's finally gone but a
plague on all your houses for keeping
him in for so long
well I I'm speaking obviously personally
um actually when you have a ministerial
post you have a responsibility with that
and as you know I was the courts
Minister and we do have a very
challenging situation in the Crown Court
so I felt Duty bound to stay in my post
but when I woke up this morning it was
pretty obvious that the situation was
you know totally untenable
um I've had no choice but to resign and
now clearly with so many of us having
done so the prime ministers realize that
the reality of the position and
hopefully we can move on
um okay just to explain to people 10 15
at this time means that that's when
we're testing the fire alarm at Mill
Bank where you are this morning so
there's nothing to worry about for
people who are watching I've lost sound
and there's a fire alarm
okay he's lost down with us if someone
can sort that out for me please do Lucy
tell me again Lucy tell me again who has
Rebecca power for environment Minister
has now also stepped down is what we're
hearing that's bringing the government
resignations in the last 48 hours to 60.
Sam coats is joining us now our Deputy
uh political editor hi to you Sam good
morning good morning
um just shows how quickly things are
moving when I I'm talking to someone who
only resigned this morning and I'm also
immediately asking him if he's going to
stay if he'll go back to his job if the
Prime Minister remains in post at least
for now
that's right okay I'm here in central
Lobby and it's hard to overstate the
sense of bewilderment that I'm coming
across with conservative MPS of all
strikes including cabinet ministers who
are wandering around open jawed at the
situation the Constitutional crisis that
we're in we're in a government that has
many many vacancies unfilled people are
unsure how it's going to operate over
the coming weeks and months I think
there is a really live debate about what
happens next in terms of the interim
period before the conservative party
gets a new leader that will happen but
the question is when and how cabinet
ministers that I've been talking to this
morning deeply deeply skeptical that
Boris Johnson could do anything like
hang on until October and there's a very
particular reason for that K that's
because people around Boris Johnson
appear to be planning a policy program
for the current prime minister for Boris
Johnson to implement in the next few
weeks and months let me just let you uh
into what people around Boris Johnson
are saying they are making clear
that frankly they are now putting
together a package to prioritize the uh
they say to prioritize the economy and
bring forward planned announcements on
tax cuts which would otherwise be
delayed by the leadership contest in
other words to put that into English
Elaine duck prime minister
is preparing to make massive decisions
consequential decisions about who should
get tax cuts whether or not there should
be more borrowing what should happen in
the economy in this cost of living
crisis right now even though exactly all
of those issues might be up for grounds
contested by the Dozen or so names uh
that you were just talking about with
Beth who might be standing for the
leadership so one cabinet Mr Francisco
how Earth could that happen sure Boris
Johnson could stay on perhaps until
September the start of September so that
they uh party in the country can have a
chance to select who is the next prime
minister but the idea that he can go on
longer than that and and this is the
specific bit enact big policy decisions
well that's just for the birds and
that's why you're getting uh ministers
coming out and starting to say a lengthy
period with Boris Johnson remaining in
office a sort of big farewell tour Tony
Blair style would be untenable if you
look in the last few moments
quasi-quarting business secretary has
just messaged on Twitter what a
depressing State of Affairs so much
needless damage caused we now need a new
leader as soon as practicable someone
who can rebuild trust heal the country
and set out a new sensible and
consistent economic approach to help
families so there you've got a cabinet
Administration going on the record with
his concern about any attempt by Boris
Johnson to cling on it's now July we're
talking about Conservative Party
Conference in October which is rumored
to be the point at which he uh Boris
Johnson is uh is considering saying that
he will stand down but that's a long
time for a country to be governed by a
caretaker effectively prime minister
Boris Johnson's Wings would be clipped
if people knew that he was leaving
office he wouldn't have the full support
to make massive decisions it appears of
lots of conservative MPS which is why
one of the big questions is just the
timetable Tory MP is actually pretty
confident that they might even be able
to whittle down that dozen or so names
to the last two that can go to the party
in the country by the end of term I
think as Beth was says July the 23rd so
we've got just under three weeks to do
that uh the sort of knockout rounds in
the past have taken uh just over a
fortnight when they've been done at PACE
as they were after the brexit vote in uh
in the race that ended up with Theresa
May in uh in post but you do have what
is increasingly amongst cabinet
ministers a sense of constitutional
crisis right now over Boris Johnson's
leaving day okay Sam thanks very much
indeed and so the controversy now moves
not from whether the Prime Minister
should resign because he will be and
he'll make a statement later on uh today
but whether he should be allowed to
remain as the interim prime minister
until a new prime minister is chosen a
process that could take several weeks
I'm just hearing from one of my cabinet
sources who says I don't think he should
be allowed to stay I think that Dominic
Robb who is the Deputy Prime Minister
should be allowed to be the case
caretaker prime minister joining us now
is Lord Hessel Thai a former deputy
prime minister hello to you my Lord
thank you for joining us what do you
think should happen should well um
yeah I'm absolutely clear that we need a
deputy prime minister to act in the
intraven before the new prime minister
has chosen uh it's quite obvious that
Boris Johnson if he actually were
allowed to stay is going to try and put
through a range of policies which will
both to his position presumably for
another go or something like that
um so that's Unthinkable we're now
dealing with a very short period in
which a new leader is chosen and there
will have to be a pause in serious
policy initiatives but the the critical
thing of course here is that Boris is
associated with one major policy and
that is is it and that is brexit and I
coined the phrase if Boris goes brexit
goes to me the big interesting dilemma
is the way in which kirstama has been
wrong footed in making these
anti-european speeches as he has so on
the basis that he was going to fight
Boris Johnson now of course the Tory
party is going to have to find a new
leader and my belief is that there will
be a a return to sanity towards our
policies about Europe which will make
kirstana look I think rather foolish and
irrelevant but certainly virus has got
to go and he mustn't be allowed to sort
of maneuver and manipulate power in the
dying days of his Premiership
but my Lord you know that the
conservative party the modern
conservative party wanted to get brexit
done that's why Jeremy Hunt failed uh
when he was in the two-horse race with
Boris Johnson 66 percent of those who
voted conservative members around the
country said they wanted Boris Johnson
and the big issue then as it is now was
brexit so any uh potential prime
minister who comes forward will not say
they want to go back into Europe
well they won't say that but they will I
think say they want a totally more
positive relationship with Europe
um and if they don't then they're going
to build the opening for the lib Dems in
the south of England uh you see people
quote what will happen in the last
general election That's History the
important thing is what is happening in
the by-elections and in public opinion
and public opinion have now seized
brexit as a disaster and the lib Dems
are winning safe seats from the
conservatives in the south of England on
the issue of Europe amongst other things
so if the Tory party is going to have a
ghost of a chance of going through the
next few months which are going to be
very difficult economically and then
being a credible party in the next
election they're going to have to revert
to that traditional conservative
position of building a power base in the
center of British politics now don't
tell me the party has put off divisions
on this subject I fully understand that
but the extreme
anti-europeanism right-wingism is in
fact a suicide course for the Tory party
in the context of the economic
circumstances we're facing
I'm going to ask you to
heard me ask it before
would best
that role
well look I'm fully aware that I'm quite
a controversial figure in the story
party so my endorsement could be toxic
and therefore I will remain like a clam
silent
uh
if I was to press you might you um
indulge me
my dad what
might you indulge me with a name if I
were to press you and ask you again
even faced with your charm I will remain
clam-like
[Laughter]
all the MPS go on their summer holidays
to try to narrow down the I mean it's
going to be a wide open race isn't it
for those that would like to uh be the
incumbent at number 10. do you think
there is enough time for conservative
MPS to narrow that down Whittle that
down to two oh yes if they want to and
the the fact is they will do it very
rapidly they're going on their holidays
they want don't want this hanging all
over the constituencies in that time the
thing of course the problem is and I
personally would change this rule I
think that the idea of putting two
people to the membership of the Tory
party is actually a a a mistake because
the membership of the Tory party is a
relatively small part of the Troy vote
and it tends to be rather activist it
tends to be rather extreme and so there
is an inbuilt instinct to go for the
populist arguments that appeal to the
Tory activists as opposed to the
critical electorate which is the one in
the center ground of British politics
okay we are going to hear from the prime
minister to confirm what we already know
that he will be resigning today what do
you think what do you want to hear from
him
uh yeah maybe a little bit more than
that potentially
well it's very difficult to know what he
can say I mean he has been a disastrous
prime minister in the conduct of the
nation's Affairs I'm fully aware that he
did a perfectly reasonable job ever
coping broadly the same as all our
European equivalents I know he's been
supportive of the Ukrainian heroic
defense and uh of course much support
that but any prime minister would have
done the same and there is that awful
feeling
reflected in Max Hastings article in the
times today above his story is an
opportunity of you know boosterism
bolsterism I'm a Churchill mini
Churchill not even a mini church
so I'm afraid the cynics
cynicism in me it tells me that Billy
when it comes to it what has Boris
achieved and Boris has achieved the
thrashing of Britain's into
International reputation the thrashing
of the reputation of the Tory party and
left us facing an economy in very
serious trouble about which the truth
needs to be told and with the Devolution
agenda which has been much talked about
actually moving at a snail's pace
both um
I was going to say of a certain age I'm
going to say experienced and we've seen
a few of these situations previously
um can you make any comparisons between
this end of days and of the Tory MPS
who've had to go
I think that there is one Stark
comparison and that is dignity
well in this case
well I mean the the fact I mean it is
now a significant period since Michael
Howard and William Hague as former
leaders of the party said that the Prime
Minister had to go we saw the 148 of his
colleagues vote against him and there of
course were many more who would have
done so in any second round and and
there has been this sort of unedifying
clinging to The Rock Against The
Inevitable prizing off and it has been a
very undignified process
and I can't think of any precedent from
all the leadership battles that I've
watched on the touch lines of no nearly
50 years in public life
as unedifying as this one
and my Lord what would you say to
um comments that I've been reading in
the papers this morning that suggested
that if a big beast like you had still
been in politics today he would not have
turned you away last night and said I'm
still staying in other words it's those
around him not just the prime minister
for now that is responsible for this
unedifying spectacle
I think that his colleagues should have
acted more decisively and earlier
but I'm afraid that I subscribe to the
view that
the cabinet is basically bothers friends
that traditional position of the good
cabinet which represents the wide
spectrum of Tory party thinking
um thank you so much uh for joining us
um twice in two days my lord it's always
a pleasure thank you thank you very much
bye thank you bye-bye
what about Jake and Bruce moggs thinks
of all this
good morning
um
the Prime Minister has my support
to go today
that's him going through the cabinet
office door don't don't be uh lulled
into a false sense of security with that
though because that door
goes straight into number 10 if they
want it to so my bet is that he's going
to be in with a PM right now perhaps
helping him write that resignation
speech uh Adam standing by hi Adam what
do you think
yeah I've been listening to your
interviews with Fascination I think
Michael Heston certainly put his finger
on it when he talked about that question
of dignity or lack of dignity in this
particular departure of a prime minister
I have to say I've just been looking at
all the various people speaking up now
saying that it's unacceptable that Boris
Johnson should be a caretaker perhaps as
long as until October uh two wings of
the conservative party uh Ruth Davidson
on the one hand saying he can't stay
Dominic Cummings on the other although
he's not officially a conservative he of
course was the senior advisor to Boris
Johnson quasi quateng has joined that
list George Freeman has joined that list
that's all within the conservative party
and then on the other hand you've got
the leaders of the opposition that we've
been hearing from Nicholas sturgeon and
Ed Davey so this is a continuing open
open saw after the news that Boris
Johnson was going to go and it may well
I think be affecting the nature of his
announcement and how he speaks to the
nation I mean we should remember Kay
that last night the Prime Minister and
the chancellor uh the new Chancellor
Nadim zahavi were planning today on
making a major economic speech to
announce uh big changes in Economic
Policy quite possibly tax cuts I don't
even know whether those speeches are
still going to go that speech is still
going to go ahead and even if it does is
it binding this is momentarily a mess
and worth noting one of the things that
Michael hasselton said to you it is
possible although I think unlikely that
the conservative MPS could speed this
process up were they to only have an
election process and then put forward
one candidate for the consideration of
the membership as we saw for example
with Michael Howard we wouldn't need to
have this extensive period of maybe six
weeks through August and September of
the party membership being balloted uh
because as it were the leader would
emerge by acclimation at Westminster
seems to me the Tory party is too Riven
with divisions and there are too many uh
ambitious politicians out there for that
to be a likely outcome but that is just
possible one way we could have a proper
prime minister uh by uh the time of the
recess at the end of this month
uh okay but you think we will get uh to
the situation where potentially
even as interim prime minister it will
be so toxic that he can't stay on
I think uh there are many people who
regarded as unacceptable now for Boris
Johnson to stay on they don't trust him
it would be unacceptable for him to as
Michael heseltine said start launching
major policy initiatives while he's a
caretaker admitted he's going and I
think it's his nature that he would want
to do that as long as he is in Downing
Street so it seems to me that the
outcome of this argument will follow the
pattern of the outcome of the argument
over whether Boris Johnson should go and
it will almost certainly be uh that it's
inappropriate for him to stay on As a
caretaker prime minister which means I
think most likely I'm not definitive but
most likely at some point maybe at the
start of the recess we'll see a
caretaker take over and I suspect that
that will probably be the Deputy Prime
Minister Dominique Robb but uh that that
at this stage is speculation because is
all these things are being actively
debated and discussed and it's clear as
Boris Johnson said yesterday to the
liaison committee uh that he's going to
fight at every step to still continue to
have a role
okay Adam for now thanks Beth back with
us hi Beth
if you just tune our way we are
in the House of Commons we'll bring that
to you just as soon as we can places
well we're just here in uh the the
foreign secretary Liz truss and would-be
Tory leadership candidate she is
definitely one that would want to run
we've been told that she's cutting short
her trip to Indonesia and she is heading
back we listen to Angela sorry
moving however it's important the house
is kept informed in films in the timely
and alternative way there are legitimate
questions requiring answers about the
functioning of government over this
turbulent period that is why I've
granted the uq we're about to hear I
remind all members that conventions and
curses are here for a purpose they allow
us to discuss the most important issues
without resorting to personal attacks
that is why I encourage all members to
remember our constituents are watching
events closely let us focus on the big
issues not the personality I now come to
the deputy leader for the uq angel
Lorena
uh thank you Mr Speaker for granting
this very important uq today to ask the
minister for the cabinet office if he
will make a statement on the functioning
of government
Minister Ellis thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
as the house will be aware
it is widely reported that the prime
minister is about to make an important
statement shortly
I can confirm that it is correct that
the Prime Minister will speak shortly
I cannot preempt the prime minister's
statement and the house and the nation
will hear more imminently
in the meantime the business of
government continues supported in the
usual Way by our excellent civil service
there will continue to be Ministers of
the crown in place
including in all great offices of State
we must continue to serve our country
constituents and the general public
first and foremost
it is our duty now to make sure the
people of this country have a
functioning government this is true now
more than ever
the civil service is the foundation on
which all governments function
the Civil Service continues to support
across all government departments and
the country can be assured that this
will always remain the case
I have spoken this morning to the
cabinet secretary to that effect
uh any uh transitional Arrangements have
always been made to allow for the
business of government to continue
there are constitutional mechanisms in
place to make sure that can happen we
await the prime minister's statement
but the house should be reassured that
the government continues to function in
the meantime
any necessary ministerial vacancies can
and will be filled other secretaries of
State can make decisions if necessary
there is a rich reserve of people who
are both dedicated and talented and who
remain dedicated to serving our country
and their constituents
calmness and professionalism are now
required
our Focus now is fully on the stability
and continuity of government Mr speaker
now is the time to serve in the
interests of our country as it always is
and our constituents During the period
ahead
[Music]
I hate to break it to the minister but
we don't have a functioning government
it will be good news for the country
that the prime minister is to announce
his resignation he was always unfit for
office he has overseen Scandal fraud and
waste on an industrial scale but the
chaos of the last three days is more
than just Petty Tory infighting these
actions Mr speak have serious
consequences for the running of our
country in the middle of the deepest
cost of living crisis of a generation
with families unable to make ends meet a
dangerous war in Europe threatening our
borders and a possible trade crisis in
Northern Ireland Britain has no
functioning government no ministers in
place to pass legislation Bill
committees canceled with no one to run
them can the minister confirm whether
the 11 committees due to take place
today will go ahead without ministers
what are the arrangements to pass
primary and secondary legislation and
who will answer oral questions how will
this government continue to be
democratically held to account with the
new education secretary resigning after
36 hours which must be a record there is
not a single member in the Department of
Education what does this mean for
children taking their exams what does
this mean for the impending child care
cost crisis and our British national
security is at risk too not least
because the Prime Minister thinks he can
stay on with the departure of the
Northern Ireland secretary only two
ministers are left able to sign security
warrants to approve Secret Service use
of sensitive Powers what contingency
plans are in place to deal with
emergencies in the short term Mr Speaker
the Prime Minister has said he will stay
on as caretaker how many more months of
chaos does this country actually have to
endure with dozens of ministerial posts
unfilled who on Earth will join the
prime minister's government now and how
will a half empty cabinet run the
country until October Mr Speaker they
will try desperately to change the
person at the top but it's the same old
Tory party and government
[Applause]
Easter I cannot preempt the prime
minister's statement and the house and
the nation will hear more very shortly
but government and the Civil Service
will continue to function in the
meantime the the business of the house
statement will be made shortly and
members can ask questions of the leader
of the House of Commons about the and
the matter of the business of this place
but the house will continue to function
and government business will continue to
function other secretaries of State can
deal with uh issues for other
departments uh constitutionally and
legally in necessary circumstances
thank you Mr Speaker without wishing to
preempt the prime minister's statement
does my right friend agree that he can
be proud of a large number of
achievements of his government
but can I invite my right friend to
preempt the opposition by making clear
that Margaret Thatcher David Cameron
Tony Blair Theresa May all left office
and was succeeded by new leaders and new
Prime Ministers without there being a
general election and that the ship of
state state sales on
he is of course completely correct
Thompson thank you Mr Speaker well I
think as I came into the chamber we were
at 59 resignations and Counting uh it's
a remarkable amount of leadership that
was shown by the junior ministerial
ranks rather than many of the cabinet
now I've been longing since I was
elected for a cabinet of remainers but
not necessarily of the kind that we've
seen clinging like limpets to a rock
no today's announcement from the the
prime minister of his intention to
resign comes after two years in 348 days
in office which uh by Supreme irony is
the same number of days as Neville
Chamberlain spent in office as prime
minister and it's a prime minister who
achieved brexit under false pretenses
purely as a a part of his game to
achieve entry to Downing Street and in
that two years in 348 days he's left
behind a trail of political chaos of
economic destruction and leaving any
reputation that the UK might have
retained as a reliable International
partner which stands up for the
international rules-based order trampled
into the Dust we regularly in Scotland
have to put up with patronizing lectures
about how well our government is
performing yet we have a government in
Westminster where we have an education
department with no education ministers
where we have six police forces in
England which are under special measures
and a government that seems utterly
paralyzed and unable to deal with the
major issues of the day the idea that
the Prime Minister can stay on and
preside over this till the Autumn is
utterly risible why how long can this
fast be allowed to continue and how is
it right at 320 MPS will get to choose
the next prime minister over that time
while denying the right of five and a
half million Scots to choose their own
future
the government and the Civil Service
will continue to function in the
meantime as they always have done and as
they have done historically
so Christopher chill
Mr Speaker may I think the Prime
Minister for his great service to our
nation and also to the people of Ukraine
and I think that people will rule the
day that he was forced to resign but but
can I can I can I say to my right
honorable friend that isn't there a lot
to be said for having a smaller cabinet
fewer ministers than hardly any
parliamentary private secretaries and
can we have a pilot to show how
successful that's going to be
the next uh well he makes a perfectly
interesting point but is somewhat
outside the range of my responsibilities
I've had here a list of all of the
resignation resignation
because I wouldn't read them out but um
there's plenty of tasty quotes in there
that will be of use later on the
minister can't sensibly argue that we
have a functioning government when this
number of people are missing there are
no people ministers to to do statutory
committees and legislation even as we
speak so what is the way forward he
can't just blather at the dispatch box
when the government's disintegrating
around them
the business of the House of Commons
okay so that's an urgent question in the
House of Commons about the running of
government confirmation also from the
government benches that we are expecting
a statement from the Prime Minister
shortly I'm hearing uh beths with us I'm
hearing it's going to be around midday
yeah so we're expecting the prime
minister to come out around midday and
make this statement and my mind's
actually get into what might he say
uh we know from the briefings from
number 10 in the past four to eight
hours and also what the Prime Minister
was saying to Cabinet ministers and
other uh parliamentarians and what he
said in the Commons too that he was
clear that he had a mandate of 14
million people who voted for him and he
really did not want to stand down and I
imagine when he comes out he will want
to run through some of his Greatest Hits
he would like have no doubt talk about
brexit getting brexit done I imagine
that he wants to talk about the pandemic
uh the vaccine roll out and I imagine uh
that it's going to be also a very very
difficult statement for him because he
is a prime minister that really did not
want to resign he clung on to the very
end even last night number 10 briefing
out that he was carrying on that they
were going to make an economic statement
that it was going to be business as
usual usual so it's going to be very
difficult for him uh to to stay on
I'm hearing that [ __ ] it is in a chipper
mode
typical of Boris Johnson yeah it's funny
actually some of the cabinet ministers
that that saw him yesterday have said
something similar to me that he was very
amicable yesterday that he was clubbable
yesterday and it might be that he just
uses that Boris Johnson bravado that we
have come uh to know so well and he
comes out and he is
full of
women Vigor wow full of vigor is a good
way of putting it he's kind of
characteristic energy boosterism Vigor
you'll remember I think we were here
together when it happened weren't we
Theresa May yep we were here weren't we
together
um and you remember that that Theresa
May came out and you remember that she
she
she lost her voice she was so emotional
she said it's been a privilege to serve
the country I love and I remember it so
well that on the country I love her
voice broke and she appeared to to shed
a tear and then she went back in like
she's only stopping as she walked yeah
it was it was her husband waiting just
behind it was a really difficult it was
a difficult thing to watch actually
because the difficulty that she had in
accepting the time was up for her she
actually it was over her face as she did
that and she's not a politician as we
know to show emotion so let's see let's
see how he handles it but I imagine that
he will want to give it some of his
trademark as I said Boris Johnson
boosterism bear with me if you would
please Beth apparently she was at the
Opera earlier on in the week it was a
Greek tragedy
make it that's what you will
um the Prime Minister another moment in
history being made with Beth and I here
in the street at number 10 uh when we
are hearing from
um hopefully around midday will be
hearing from the Prime Minister as he
makes his resignation speech stay tuned
to Sky News for that it's being made
possible in part because of the actions
of somebody like the conservative MP
Robin Walker who resigned as the schools
Minister earlier on today hello to Mr
Walker thanks for joining us what took
you so long hello
um I I resigned yesterday
um and was I think the fourth minister
to resign I I think for a lot of us we
wanted to give the Prime Minister every
chance to try and put things right to
try and sort out uh some of the problems
that we've seen in Downing Street but
had come to a conclusion uh but he
hadn't been able to do that and that
therefore
um I didn't see that I could criticize
others when Sajid and Rishi went uh I
didn't see that I could necessarily
defend the position of the Prime
Minister and I felt it was the right
thing to offer my resignation
yeah again why did it take you so long
as I say because we wanted to give him
every chance to try and put things right
and we we asked for assurances and we
received them but changes were being
made at Downing street that the culture
had changed and that the the the things
were going to be done differently in the
future unfortunately I think what we saw
with the Chris pincher Affair is that
they they weren't being done differently
and we saw the same uh approach of
absolute denials uh that we had seen on
on earlier issues where we had raised
similar concerns uh it was that I think
that led so many colleagues
independently to make up their minds uh
to go and to say that we have to have a
change of leadership I'm glad that that
has now been accepted I'm glad that we
now have do have a situation where the
party in the country will be able to
move forward uh where we can move into
selecting a new leader as swiftly as
possible and I think it's essential that
we but we have that choice
now not my words but others um from the
opposition bench he's saying you're a
group of absolute charlatans and you
should definitely have done it before
now the writing was on the wall
well they would say that wouldn't they I
mean I think it's absolutely right when
you have a prime minister who's elected
with a majority but you give him every
opportunity to deliver on the Promises
on which he was elected and uh on a
number of occasions many of us in
government have raised concerns about
some of the issues in Downing Street we
were apologized to we were given
assurances but things were changing but
some of the people were changing I think
the problem is uh that the Prime
Minister has not been able to win back
for Trust of his colleagues and and that
is why many of us reluctantly took the
decision but although we're passionate
about the jobs we're doing for the
country and for uh the government we
couldn't carry on doing them under his
leadership now that issue is now
resolved he's accepted that uh and and
after uh I think an unnecessarily
protracted uh 24 hours uh in which so
many good colleagues had to sacrifice
their ministerial careers we're now in a
position where we can move forward I
think it's important but we resume the
business of government as swiftly as
possible make sure that we are
delivering on those priorities on which
we were acted but crucially also allow
the party to move forward and get on
with having a leadership contest so that
we can take choose the right person to
take us forward
I I think there will be a number of
strong candidates coming forward in the
later head I personally hope that um
having shown the Integrity that he has
and consistently shown leadership and
integrity Sachi Javid will be among them
but I think there there are a number of
colleagues who have the ideas and the
passion my my former boss Nadim zahawi I
think has shown a strong start in the
role of Chancellor and wanting to
prioritize tax cuts that's something a
lot of us want to see and have been
pushing for uh for a long time but there
are a number of strong colleagues
potentially In Contention I want to see
what is the feel that emerges I want to
see how those people perform and how
they answer the questions on how we can
deliver on that crucial 2019 Manifesto
because that is what gave the party the
majority to take this country forward
and that is the promises that we've made
for public which we need to focus on
delivering
uh how okay let me ask you this how long
do you think the Prime Minister should
remain as interim prime minister until
we get a new prime minister uh in other
words should he stay on until the Autumn
well look at the Constitutional
precedent is that um the Prime Minister
does tend to stay on until their
successor has been elected that is as
was just said in the House of Commons um
the established precedent that happened
with Tony Blair um with John Margaret
Thatcher and others but I think the uh
there is a question for the
Parliamentary party here and uh I know
some colleagues will feel very strongly
that they don't think uh the current
prime minister should stay in post I
have to say I think the priority should
be getting on with the business of
government and making sure that we do
have a government but can deliver uh for
the country and I'm not going to rule
out any particular individual as being
that caretaker prime minister I think
the crucial thing is we need to get on
and hold the leadership election as
quickly as possible we need to make sure
that we can take get a strong leader to
take the party forward and someone who
can unite the party that's not going to
be an easy easy task but it's a
crucially important one it's a crucially
important one for all of our
constituents and for all parts of
government where we need to get on with
delivering a positive agenda
yeah we seem to have lost focus a little
bit on that camera there rather like the
Prime Minister has over the last couple
of days or so
um isn't that what Deputy Prime
Ministers are for though shouldn't they
shouldn't it be Dominic Raab who's
filling in until we've got a new pm
well as I say I I'm not ruling out any
individual I I I I think the important
thing is we get this decided we get it
decided quickly if if colleagues across
the Parliamentary party feel it's not
right for the prime minister to stay on
a caretaker a role I would accept that
if colleagues are across the party uh
feel that they can continue add indeed
many of his predecessors did I would
accept that too I think the most
important thing now is that we do need
to make sure that the business of
government can go ahead we do need to
make sure that this leadership election
takes place as swiftly as possible and
with a stronger field of candidates as
possible I want there to be a genuine
Battle of ideas about how we can deliver
on that 2019 Manifesto effectively how
we can deal with the cost of living
crisis how we can deliver their tax cuts
but people and that businesses need now
in order to strengthen the economy and
make sure that we go for growth I think
all of these things are crucially
important I think we have a short window
of time to hold that contest and to get
that decided so that we can then move
forward decisively uh in the latter half
of this year okay it's good to talk to
you thanks so much indeed for joining us
on the program this morning thank you
well what a morning it's been on an
extended version of the breakfast show
here on Sky News today uh coming up
within about the next hour or so we are
expecting Boris Johnson the present
prime minister to walk out of that door
and when he does he's going to be
resigning his post he's done absolutely
everything to stay in post some of his
big dogs as they're called went in to
see him yesterday said the game is up
it's all over prime minister time for
you to resign he took absolutely no
notice of them he said he was going to
remain in post this morning his Northern
Ireland secretary resigned lots of other
people in between also resigned but then
his Chancellor made public a statement
saying prime minister you have to go and
you have to go now was that the Tipping
Point for Boris Johnson to say okay the
game's up Beth Rigby and Sophie reach
will be here in just a moment
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello this is Sky News Today Live from
Downing Street it's 11 o'clock the
headlines
Boris Johnson is to resign as prime
minister less than three years after
entering Downing streets
he's inside number 10 right now and we
are expecting a statement shortly
his resignation followed yet more
resignations today the number who've
quit the government is now over 50. and
already MPS are calling for the prime
minister to leave Downing Street now and
to hand over to a caretaker leader
we'll be looking back on the career of
the man who secured brexit brought down
by parties and a sex scandal
[Music]
well it is over after an unprecedented
48-hour power struggle with his MPS
Boris Johnson has agreed to resign as
prime minister more ministerial
departures taking the total number to
over 59 and a public letter from its
newly appointed to Chancellor appeared
to have finally convinced him that it's
time to go now the issue is whether he
stays on until a new leader is elected
that will be by the conservative party
or whether he leaves sooner these are
the key issues now I can tell you that
the conversations that I've been having
with number 10 that the prime minister
is currently trying to fill some of
those vacancies in his government we
know that there are an awful lot after
the uh all of those resignations that
happened and apparently according to
number 10 they are being accepted
whether or not that is true we'll
obviously be testing in the hours to
come our political editor Beth Rigby is
with us now so we know that he's going
to resign I think the question I guess
is whether he can stay on
so you mean whether he can stay
organization yeah that's being contested
at the moment there are uh some cabinet
ministers that are saying to me that
they are happy for him there's robotsie
who's just come out he is uh Nadine
dory's advisor now you know Nadine Doris
is uh one of Boris Johnson's most loyal
supporters so he coming out now I wonder
if Nadine Dory is is in there as the
Prime Minister uh finishes off that
resignation statement but look there's a
couple of things uh going on this
morning as you said uh questions about
whether or not they can convince other
people to come back in and serve in
government given that there are now I
think it uh let me look at the screen
I've lost count 59 government
resignations and the five cabinet
ministers five cabinet ministers have
also stood down in the past uh 24 hours
so that needs sorting out and and people
I'm sure will be asked to serve because
ultimately what the gov we can't have
now is a government that can't govern
given what we are about to lose a prime
minister and a conservative party leader
but then the question is about Boris
Johnson and and can he stay on and I've
had different conversations this morning
with different sources some cabinet
ministers telling me that they think
it's okay for him to stay on and hand
over power one saying to me that there
is a constitutional precedent that that
is done but you've seen with some former
ministers and and uh MPS making it clear
that they don't think he should stay on
that they would rather have a caretaker
government there was a report by uh the
brilliant Jason Groves actually in the
mail last night the political editor of
the Daily Mail that there was some talk
about Theresa May coming back As a
caretaker prime minister so that is a
live discussion at the moment but but
where are we now right here we don't get
too far ahead of ourselves we're
expecting him to come out as Kay was
saying she had heard midday I've been
told it's a bit fluid around lunchtime
we expect him to come out to stand at
the podium and make this resignation
speech and the tone of that would be
really fascinating to see won't it I
mean this is a man who it feels like try
to resist the resignation right until
the last possible minute and what time
do you think knowing Bros Johnson had
interviewed him like many times and what
sort of tone do you think he will strike
when he does come out here for his big
moment well it has been the most
staggering 24 hours in modern politics
that I have ever covered and I'm quite
old now I've been doing this job for
quite a long time it really has been
quite astonishing to watch this unfold
and on Tuesday night when such a Javid
and Rishi sunak resigned at that point
we said and Molly my producer and I said
we think this is the moment this is the
moment that is going to begin The
Snowball Effect remember the cabinet
rallied around actually and but the next
morning these resignations but through
all of this astonishing 48 Hours uh one
thing stayed true and that was Boris
Johnson's commitment to staying in there
and it was literally only when Brandon
Lewis this morning resigned uh at dawn I
woke up to it on my phone Simon Hart
resigning at 11 o'clock last night
swella bravaman his attorney General on
the peston show last night saying that
she no longer supports him and also
saying that she wanted to run herself it
was only really when Dawn broke and the
realization dropped for him that
whatever he wanted he had no cabinet
couldn't feel Pace he couldn't stay on
so you just asked me what do I think the
time will be it's been defiant up to now
but I've been told by people that have
had conversations with him last night
and this morning that the mood is
amicable that he is upbeat if anything
and I imagine that what he would want to
do as he addresses not all of us here
although I mean there are hundreds of uh
yeah
there's a very full street but it's he's
not really addressing us he's addressing
the entire country and he wanted to stay
on because he believed that he had he
said it in the Commons yesterday at pmqs
a colossal mandate where his was 14
million people had voted for him and he
will want to speak to those people and I
imagine that what he will want to do is
present uh with his Vigor and Vim and
boosterism that has come to characterize
uh his his time at number 10 but it must
be so difficult for him Sophie I mean he
is now was a prime minister that has
elected with 80 seat majority he thought
he might go two times he thought he
might go three I mean he was saying that
just two weeks ago to Jonas in Rwanda
and actually the reality is he will come
out of there and he will end his
Premiership as one of the shortest
serving conservative prime ministers in
history I do Wonder uh because obviously
he as you say he would be one of the
shortest in history if he does make it
to Autumn I believe that he then
overtakes Theresa May I wonder if that's
at the back of his mind slightly someone
was definitely concerned about his
legacy he was concerned about his legacy
and he he he's competitive so he wanted
to beat David Cameron he wanted to be
Theresa May now I've got a great
relationship anyway he will find it very
difficult having to stand down midterm
and also you can imagine that he feels
quite angry about it because he will
feel like he won these seats for these
MPS he got brexit over the line he broke
the impasse back in 2019 and now he has
to go but this is not a presidential
situation it's a parliamentary democracy
you might get a mandate from the people
but you have to have the confidence of
your cabinet and your parliamentary
party to stay on as prime minister and
once you've lost that you're out of
power you're not stay in office I'm
interested to know your thoughts on
whether he will be able to stay into the
Autumn which we know is what he wants to
do I think that's
I think it's very contested
um and you know I'm speaking to some
cabinet ministers as saying I think so I
spoke to another who said I simply don't
know a couple of cabinet ministers said
to me that they thought he should be
able to so it's it's quite contestant
moment what we can say for sure is his
intention is that he wants a orderly
Handover of power as he would see it he
would like to stay on and see through
the summer and then once a new
conservative leader is in place by
Kansas Party Conference he will step
down but you know Sophie on this as well
with the timings yeah yeah I don't know
what will happen yet I mean with the
Theresa May situation we thought we're
going to have a leadership race and in
the end she was anointed prime minister
with Boris Johnson we went through
rounds and rounds as we how did we have
we had such a Javid and Jeremy Hunt
Boris Johnson there was
um Rory Stewart who else was James
Cleveland James
Michael Gove do you remember Michael so
you know there are half a dozen of them
Dominic Raab they all launched their
leadership bids and then it was whittled
down and I we've already seen people
coming out the blocks already right yeah
so so that so the thing is this time and
this is what a former cabinet minister
told me last night as we were talking
very late into the night they said the
issue here for the party and for
government now is there's no plan B it's
not like the Parliamentary party ousted
Boris Johnson because they had a
pretender or they had a PM in waiting in
the way that Theresa May was outed
because there was a big group in the
party that wanted to put a brexite in
that's not the situation here they've
literally got him out because they don't
want him to be prime minister anymore
because they think it's a drag anchor on
the conservative ground because they no
longer want to serve under him so they
don't have a plan D and B so in that
sense it's quite wide open this race and
I guess because of that they are going
to need some kind of caretaker leader in
the months ahead while the leadership
contest plays out will it be dominant
Robb will it be Theresa May as you were
mentioning all the other question
against is whether Boris Johnson is
allowed to stay on to do that he would
then need of course people that have
resigned handed in those resignation
letters to say that they haven't got
trust in him to effectively re-accept
their jobs or to find enough people in
the back benches to fill it do you think
it's possible
to stay on will the party let him and
the cabinet from my conversations with
the number of people today is divided on
that and number two how on Earth are
they going to fill those 59 government
posts now some of them are ministerial
aides but you know there are a number of
cabinet posts vacant and there are a
number of minister of states of senior
ministerial roads those roles will have
to be filled and there will be a
discussion going on in there at the
moment about whether or not they can
bring cabinet ministers back or whether
they can bring those ministers back into
place to thanks thank you so much Beth
we'll have plenty more calls from this
school editor Beth Rigby as the
afternoon goes on but what we can tell
you of course is that in number 10 Boris
Johnson is attempting to fill some of
those vacant roles but let's go to
Adaptive shall we now some coats is in
Parliament Central Lobby uh for us Sam
what have you been hearing
bewilderment I think from conservative
MPS as people try to navigate this
frankly constitutional crisis the latest
in the last few moments is there are
some cabinet ministers I'm being told
that are currently trying to unresign
get back into their posts because it's
so uncertain whether Boris Johnson
continues for weeks or months with a
Dominic robber another caretaker comes
along what we also know is that there
are people very close to Boris Johnson
who are effectively trying to drop a
legacy for him he wants to do tax cuts
in however much long uh in whatever uh
in whatever form he can in whatever time
he has left but the question safely is
what happens next and we have some
intelligence this morning you gov
conducted a poll of conservative members
the people who were going to determine
the next story leader and hence the next
conservative prime minister who will
succeed Boris Johnson and it has found
that in Pole Position the person who
would succeed Boris Johnson according to
this poll is Ben Wallace the defense
secretary you guys Tory members poll
makes clear that Ben Wallace beats Liz
trust the foreign secretary Penny
mordant Richie sunac who was Chancellor
and Jeremy Hunt Liz truss comes out
second penny more than third and Liz
truss and then Jeremy Hunt way below
clearly some of the dozen or so names uh
not in that poll Nadim Sahari for
instance Zoella Braverman Steve Baker
weren't polled but Ben Wallace the
defense secretary who has been at Boris
Johnson's side all all the way through
is coming out on top according to this
Tory members poll he would beat Liz
truss by 48 of Tory members to 29 who'd
vote for uh Liz truss just above how
much he would beat Petty Morton by uh uh
and uh Rishi sunak by a similar margin
as well this would be remarkable because
Ben Wallace he has been a long time
Boris Johnson supporter he's earned his
Spurs particularly uh not only through
the withdrawal of Afghanistan but more
recently through his handling of Ukraine
crisis he routinely comes out top of
other membership service surveys
particularly the one by conservative
home but here's the thing Sophie that
would mean that Tory members who are
overwhelmingly brexit actually are
considering are happy to consider a
remainer to succeed Boris Johnson that's
a remarkable turnaround that tells you
quite a lot about where the party is at
the moment pushing down brexit perhaps
as a priority rise using up other issues
such as Statesmen like leadership and
ability to engage on the media those are
the kind of qualities that Ben Wallace
has been admired for by Tory MPS and
those are the kinds of reasons that the
membership might be lining up behind Ben
Wallace we're in for a hell of a contest
it's quite possible that MPS will have
to whittle down the field from the dozen
or so people likely to stand down to the
last two candidates possibly even before
the summer recess in less than three
weeks but as it stands if those last two
candidates include Ben Wallace MPS put
him through he beats pretty much any
other Contender including those who've
been hard at it with behind the scenes
leadership campaigns for some time
thank you very much Sam Sam Cooked
they're reporting for us in central
Lobby right there in the heart of
Westminster uh while we're waiting of
course for the prime minister's
statement potentially expecting that
around at midday we're told that we will
be hearing some ministerial appointments
shortly as Boris Johnson tries to dig in
and allow himself to remain in post As a
caretaker leader until the Autumn well
let's bring in Adam Bolton shall we the
former Sky News political editor and
presenter Adam good to see you again in
the Sky News studio
um have you ever seen anything like this
in your long time as a political episode
no I've never seen this anything like
this before because even although it may
have been a very uh sad and emotional
time we've always had an orderly
transition of power we've always known
uh who is taking over even for an
interim period And by and large the
existing government of the outgoing
leader has stayed in place now on this
occasion we don't know who's in
government and who isn't because they've
been these more than 50 resignations as
you heard Boris Johnson the outgoing
prime minister is saying he's going to
make new ministerial appointments
they're very senior figures in the
conservative party let alone Beyond it
saying that it's inappropriate that
Boris Johnson should stay on as
caretaker so the the sheer mess
A's characteristic of Boris Johnson but
it's not something we've ever seen
before in a transition of prime minister
and secondly of course the nature of
this departure is very important it's
all about the character and the behavior
of one man it's not a policy issue uh in
any sense and again that is uh new if
you like in British politics uh even uh
with the departure of Margaret Thatcher
which of course uh was after uh three
general election victories and a great
many transformative uh political
experiences yes it was true that people
were fed up with her increasingly
high-handed ways but in the end at the
heart of it was a policy issue about her
treatment of the European Union and its
allies and her attitude she was adopting
towards further European integration so
again policy was at the heart of it and
Michael hasseltine was very much the
focus of that opposition although course
he didn't emerge as leader now on this
occasion we don't really have any
significant policy disagreements critics
of the government would say that that's
because we haven't had any significant
policy initiatives Beyond getting brexit
done and we're left with very important
issues such as
negotiating changes to the Northern
Ireland protocol uh in the balance and
we also of course were expecting today a
major economic statement by the new
Chancellor Nadim zahawi with the Prime
Minister quite possibly bringing forward
tax cuts now we don't know if that's
going ahead we also don't know really
what the stages of Mr zahawi has given
this extraordinary uh 48 Hours when
first of all he took the position of
chance surrender Boris Johnson and then
this morning issued a public letter
saying he thought Boris Johnson should
Stand Down in those circumstances can he
with any credibility present A New
Economic Policy so the chaos and the
focus on one individual Boris Johnson
are unique to this situation we've never
seen the like of it
thank you very much Adam Bolton always
interesting to hear your thoughts on
these kind of occasions
well as we wait for the prime minister's
statements here in Downing Street we
wait to hear whether or not he is
managing to fill at some of those
industrial jobs whether people are
agreeing to serve in the sort of
temporary cabinet we can now speak to
David liddington he was the former
cabinet honor of office Minister and
also the former Chancellor of the Dashie
of Lancaster under Theresa May thank you
very much for being with us
um it's a little bit different isn't it
Mr lidington compared to a Theresa May's
last days in office what do you make of
the way that boss Johnson has chosen to
resign
I I think it's it's a good thing uh in
my view that he's he's decided to to go
today I think I think that this does
give him the chance to leave office with
uh at least uh some measure of of
dignity rather than be hauled out
um after another vote of no confidence
next week
um uh uh and um so I think it's it's the
it's it's the best way available forward
for the country and for the conservative
party now
Boris Johnson has said that he wants to
effectively remain in post As a
caretaker leader until the Autumn by
which time there will be a time for the
conservative party to appoint a new
leader do you think you should be given
that time or do you think the party
should act now and appoint a different
caretaker leader
I think that's up to conservative MPS
it's a question of whether in the light
of what's happened
um the Parliamentary party yes it's a
mixture of the 1922 committee and the
the those who still remain in office
particularly those who stood in the
cabinet as to whether they they want
um Mr Johnson to continue whether they
want uh what's your view you must have a
view on this I mean yeah well I mean my
view
is that it would probably be cleaner if
he just gave way to Dominic Rob
um and that Dominic act as a caretaker
leader which he did perfectly
competently while
um Mr Johnson was so ill with kovid a
couple of years ago
um and what what's important I think is
whether it's Boris Johnson or whether
it's John RAB or somebody else they
observe the limitations that they would
be in such a period I mean when David
Cameron when Theresa May uh Tony Blair
going further back in this sort of
interim period while their success was
being chosen
um they they couldn't launch any new
initiatives they could try to do a
certain amount of stuff to demonstrate a
a legacy they would be available to take
the essential decisions of government
we are supporting Ukraine in a major war
in Europe there could be a terrorist or
Cyber attack on this country at any time
that's something every prime minister
has to live with constantly so somebody
has to be available to respond and take
decisions in the cases of emergency and
to make sure the business of government
ticks over
but no more than that I mean you know
there can't be any question of uh
caretaker prime minister having the
authority to launch some great new
program that's going to require fresh
legislation so so I think it's observing
the limitations making sure that whoever
is caretaker consults with the potential
leadership contenders uh so that there
is a smoother transition as possible to
whoever is elected to succeed Boris
Johnson
interesting stuff thank you very much
for coming on the program and giving us
your thoughts David lyddington there
we can talk now to Chris philp the
concept of MP who resigned as a minister
for technology and the digital economy
and protest about Boris Johnson's
leadership he resigned earlier this
morning let's bring in Mr philp at now
shall we you of course I think will
probably be familiar to many of our
viewers as someone who's gone out to
defend Boris Johnson time and time again
what made you change your mind and
decide that he's no longer hello having
a little trouble hearing you because
I've got multiple sound channels coming
through and but eventually I was just
unable to
uh reconcile
hello
I've got multiple sounds
we can hear you if you want to keep
talking uh understand if it's a bit
impossible for you though
okay we'll go we'll come back to you
shall we
let's we'll come back to uh Chris built
when we try and re-establish a
communication with him let's bring Adam
Bolton back in at now shall we and Adam
I'm interested to know your thoughts
there David liddington telling us that
he thinks it would be cleaner for
Dominic RAV the Deputy Prime Minister to
effectively step in As a caretaker
leader although saying how important it
is effectively that he uh whoever he is
follows the rules if you like or the the
expectation that there'll be no major
policy announcements do you think uh do
you think that we will end up with Boris
Johnson being able to continue until the
Autumn or do you think that is actually
more likely that we could see someone
such as Dominic Robb taking over
I think there is an emerging consensus
uh really coming from senior politicians
on all side that in these circumstances
it would be inappropriate for Boris
Johnson to stay on As a caretaker prime
minister uh now that he's agreed he's
going I mean I've just been looking at a
list of conservatives ranging from uh
Ruth Davidson
and uh uh and quasi-quarting all the way
through to the leaves of the opposition
parties all saying it's just not
appropriate in this area and that's
because in a sense this whole matter
Boris Johnson is going because of a
breakdown in trust in him and can you
possibly allow someone whose own party
are getting rid of him because they've
lost trust in him to be anywhere near
the levers of power for the next three
months a lot of people regard that as
being pretty difficult and we have had
uh periods before when there's been a
transition in party leadership where
they've been caretakers taking charge
but I suspect behind closed doors in
Downing Street this is an argument that
is still going on and I suspect Boris
Johnson is fighting pretty hard uh to
have the opportunity to give himself a
rousing send-off possibly with some
policy decisions that's certainly the
message which we're getting from the
news that he's still talking about uh
making fresh government appointments I
doubt that he will prevail and I think
it would be very damaging for the
conservative party going forward if he
does but
um who can tell there aren't uh written
rules about these circumstances of
transition
uh interesting stuff Adam thank you very
much well I'm told we can now return to
Chris philp hopefully you should be able
to hear me a little bit more clearly at
this time so I guess my question to you
this morning is do you accept that Boris
Johnson can carry on As a caretaker
leader until the Autumn or do you think
that he does actually need to step aside
and let someone else do that
well I think there are a couple of
things firstly we need to make sure that
we keep the basic functions of
government going that's really important
there are for example uh no ministers
and DFC at the moment that needs to be
sorted out secondly I think we need to
try and select a new leader as quickly
as we reasonably can and obviously we
need to make sure we make the correct
choice and we should do it in a
reasonably quick time in terms of Boris
staying on the convention is that the
outgoing prime minister does carry on
that's what happened when uh Theresa May
left office is what happened when David
Cameron left office and yeah given that
as we just heard
um the caretaker prime minister can't
really introduce any new policy or any
significant new legislation and I don't
really see any uh major problem but I
haven't really given a deep thought to
be honest
and we can hear the noisy band behind
you so thank you for battling uh on with
that in the background just to be
Crystal Clear then uh you're talking
about the kind of Convention of a
caretaker leader would you accept Boris
Johnson staying on until the Autumn so
if he asks you for example uh to serve I
gave you a job would you accept it
well I think all of us um in public life
are here to serve the country and if I
was able to do that in whatever capacity
then obviously I'd be happy to serve I
mean when I left when I resigned this
morning one of the things that I really
weighed heavily on my mind was the fact
that I was working on bringing forward
the gambling review with reading our
gambling legislation for the first time
in 17 years because I want to be really
clear you resigned this morning but if
Boris Johnson now that he has set out a
timetable for leaving if he asked you to
re-accept a job you would say if I was
asked to help out with getting the
Online safety Bill to Parliament okay I
would be willing to help out in whatever
way I could right in any capacity
whoever the leader was whoever the
circumstances were because that's a
matter of public service I'm not
bothered to be clear I'm not asking for
that I'm not expecting it and I resigned
and when you resign you resign right but
if I can help them out practically
obviously I'll give them practical
assistance
throwing forwards because I'm not asking
yeah to be clear
don't don't worry that's come across
loud and clear but if if it were to be
offered then I think we know what the
answer would be that's that is also
clear I'm interested to know because
we're going to have a leadership contest
obviously
um is there any standout candidates that
you would like to see throw their hat in
the in the ring to be honest I only
resigned from government a few hours ago
as you just said so I haven't given that
any thought until I mean some colleagues
have been thinking about this obviously
I'm not one of them because I was just
busy getting on with things like the
gambling review and the Online safety
Bill until just a few hours ago so
that's not a topic I've really thought
about
okay a very understandable uh there and
I'm gonna have to leave it there uh
thank you very much for being with us
and Mr philpin giving us some lines
there we can now go back to our
political editor Beth Rigby who's with
us in Downing Street this morning Betsy
got some breaking lines for us well yeah
there's some developing news now I'm
told that a new cabinet is going to be
announced shortly that Boris Johnson is
filling those posts that have been
vacated in the past 24 hours I've been
told that Greg Clark you might remember
him he was the former business secretary
in a key remainer under Theresa May a
summarily sacked by Boris Johnson when
he became leader and he became one of
those groups of MPS I think at one point
maybe even the whip was withdrawn from
him from memory I'd need to check that
he is going back to become the leveling
up secretary of state so replacing uh
Michael Gove and we uh we haven't got
any other names yet sure but some rumors
about a promotion for Connor Burns one
of Boris Johnson's loyalist lieutenants
and maybe about Kit Morehouse two again
we were talking about him yesterday the
police Minister that was part of the
delegation that told Boris Johnson that
it was time to go but didn't himself as
I might he get promoted too so we were
talking about the need to fill posts and
government the need to make sure that
the country and departments around
Whitehall can function of Boris Johnson
before he makes uh that statement of
resignation we're expecting an
announcement on a
a filled cabinet that's astonishing
really isn't it the Greg Clark is one of
the first names to come out on that
really important job leveling up Beth
obviously one of the key parts of Boris
Johnson's whole legislative program do
you think that shows how so I've jumped
because I keep seeing the door I expect
too right as well any moment of that
door anyone comes out who's going to
walk up I don't know if they'll do the I
mean normally in a cabinet reshuffle
this is the weirdest one I've ever known
of but normally in a cabinet Shuffle
they they walk up so we know who's
coming next
do you think that indicates you know the
difficulties that um he's going to be
having and filling some of these
positions but part of the part of the
issue for Boris Johnson when he became
prime minister in 2019 is that he sorry
one of the problems in 2019 for Boris
Johnson or one of his decisions rather
was that he made a cabinet that was a
brexiteer cabinet he just he had such a
big majority he felt he didn't need to
bring together other parts of the party
he basically sacked every single person
that was a remain at Jeremy Hunt who was
his contender in the leadership race he
was gone despite all his ministerial uh
experience and that raised eyebrows
amongst people they thought you know
Jeremy Hunt has run a race against you
he's lost but he's a good cabinet
minister in the eyes of many of his
colleagues and you've boosted him out
Greg Clark booted out who else Damian
green who served onto trees may he was
is gone and even people like Penny
Morden who supported brexit but went for
a different leadership candidate it felt
that they were perhaps punished in some
of those cabinets well Penny Morden um
was also
um yeah kicked out of cabinet although
she's now a minister of state and what's
interesting about Penny Morden is that
we were all expecting her to resign that
she was on resignation watch and and she
didn't but we do expect that Penny
mordant will make a run for it as one of
the leading uh brexiteer candidates but
going back to Greg Clark he was an arch
remainer he was one of the gang with
Amber Roger remember how the foreign the
former home secretary that she's now out
of government with Oliver lettwin do you
remember him he was a former Minister I
mean and Greg Clark these were some of
the names at Rory Stewart they were the
people that really challenged Boris
Johnson on brexit and they um and there
is and they were the people that in the
end got kicked out of government so for
Greg Clark to come back to becoming the
leveling up Minister I mean it just
shows that well what does it show bars
that the game's over for Boris Johnson
now so he's just trying to fill the post
rather than build a loyal team around
him and also Greg Clark's a safe Pair of
Hands I mean he's the chair of the
technology select committee who was the
business secretary of state so he is a
he is a capable minister to run that
department for him and given that Boris
Johnson sacked Michael gave I don't
think it's going to be very easy to get
him back yeah I think that's probably at
her very well completed so Beth thank
you very much we'll obviously come back
to you with any more breaking lines as
well so Greg Clark there appointed the
new leveling up secretary replacing the
sacked at Michael Gove and it does
certainly feel now that Boris Johnson is
digging in that he is trying to
re-appill at some of those vacant roles
Greg Clark has obviously agreed to serve
we understand Chris philp there the
junior Minister who resigned just this
morning at telling us that he would be
prepared to serve again if Boris Johnson
was to ask him so does does this mean
that he will get his wish at being able
to stay until Autumn we're going to find
out in the hours ahead we can speak now
to Sarah Southern who is a former a
conservative advisor thank you very much
for being on the program Sarah do you
think Boris Johnson will be able to stay
on until the autumn
I really hope he doesn't I think it's
time that he he moved on one thing that
has happened in previous leadership
contests is that people think they can
set their timeline as to when they will
walk out of number 10. it happened to
David Cameron you know he thought he
would have three months I think he ended
up having about three weeks from uh you
know the brexit result through to
Theresa May walking into number 10. so
hopefully it will be quite a quick
transition
uh we're hoping it will be a quick air
transition but certainly all the noises
from uh number 10 it does feel as if
Boston would like to stay until the
Autumn as a conservative yourself how
concerned are you about the damage to
the party brand that has been done over
the last well I was going to say a few
days but really it's been a few weeks
hasn't it with the kind of changing
lines on various scandals on a Feeling
among many conservative MPS that there
is a lack of Integrity in number 10. how
easy will it be for the conservatives to
shake off that reputation
well this has been months you know I as
a party activist myself I've totally
disengaged with the party I wasn't
involved in any of the local elections
I can't admit that I even supported them
in the local elections so there are
certainly people who have felt totally
distanced uh from the party in recent
months because of what's gone on we want
to see the party come back together have
a leader that we can unite behind that
we can then you know put together a
really strong government so that when we
do go into a general election in 23 or
24 we're able to really support that
okay I thank you so much interesting to
get your thoughts there Sarah Southern
their former Aid to David Cameron
well it's been a difficult a few days
for the conservative party no doubt we
can get the reaction now from uh kiers
starmer he has been talking in
Westminster this morning let's have a
listen to what he had to say
he needs to go completely none of this
nonsense about clinging on for a few
months he's inflicted lies fraud and
Chaos in the country and you know we're
stuck with a function with a government
which isn't functioning in the middle of
a cost of living crisis and all of those
that have been propping him up should be
utterly ashamed of themselves we've had
12 years of a stagnant economy 12 years
of broken Public Services 12 years of
empty promises enough is enough and the
change we need is not a change at the
top of the Tory party it's much more
fundamental than that we need a change
of government and a fresh start for
Britain it doesn't look like he'll get a
general election if he just swaps
leaders he needs to go he can't cling on
in this way his own party have finally
concluded that he's unfit to be prime
minister they can't now inflicting on
the country for the next few months it's
obvious he's unfit to be prime minister
that's been blindingly obvious for a
very very long time and if they don't
get rid of him then labor will step up
in the National interest and bring a
vote of no confidence because we can't
go on with this prime minister Clinging
On for months and months to come
wouldn't that unite the conservative
party
I don't think anything is going to unite
this conservative party they're tearing
each other apart and what we've got in
the middle of a cost of living crisis is
a government that can't function and
that's why I say he can't cling on now
they've declared him unfit to be prime
minister they can't inflict him on the
country for the next few months if they
don't get rid of him we will bring that
vote with no confidence in the National
interest because we can't go on with
this broken government led by this
discredited prime minister
Boris Johnson in some ways was your
biggest asset if you were going to go to
the country when you lose him you will
have more of a problem won't you look
the conservative party has been in power
for 12 years 12 years of a stagnant
economy 12 years of broken Public
Services 12 years of empty promises
we need a fresh start and that's why I
say changing the person at the top of
the conservative party is not the
fundamental change that we need we need
a change of government we need a fresh
start for our country
but it doesn't look like you will get
the general election you would want now
does it well we need fundamental the
country's crying out for change we've
been stuck with a government that's not
been functioning in the middle of a cost
of living crisis and now changing the
person at the top of the conservative
party is not going to make any
difference whatsoever people want change
a fresh start for Britain and that means
we need a change of government we need a
labor government
is there nobody that you would rate as a
good opponent someone will be in against
you for me this isn't a question about
who leads the conservative party it's
much more fundamental than that they've
been in power for 12 years of empty
promises broken promises a stagnant
economy wages very very low inflation
and prices through the roof we need
fundamental change we need a fresh start
for Britain we need a change of
government we need a labor government
lastly I just want to ask you given what
you say about the government you haven't
cut through as you might want to how can
you do something about that now
we've come from a general election in
2019 when we did very badly to local
elections this year where we made
considerable ground I mean our
by-election win two weeks ago today in
Wakefield with a huge swing to the labor
party so we're on track and that's why
we say the change we need is a change of
government a labor government we're
ready for that
thank you Mr Thomas
the leader of the labor party giving his
reaction after Boris Johnson said he is
going to step down he said that Boris
Johnson can't cling on any longer he's
obviously unfit for prompt to be a prime
minister and he said that if conserved
MPS do allow him to stay on for the
months that he would like until the
Autumn he said that labor will bring a
vote of no confidence so in other words
labor will try and force Boris Johnson
from office if his own party don't do it
instead the country is crying out for
change he went on to say all of those
who have propped him up should be
ashamed of themselves well let's bring
in Adam Bolton at Sharon the former Sky
newspaper editor and presenter for some
reaction to those words from Kier
stammer um Adam it's quite difficult
isn't for all oppositions uh just a
really fun space in these uh moments
what did you make of what Kirsten had to
say well first of all that was the
leader of the the opposition adding his
voice to those people saying it is
unacceptable for Boris Johnson to stay
on As a caretaker prime minister until
the conservatives have chosen a new
leader and saying that he would try and
use really the only weapon the
opposition have in these circumstances
of tabling a vote of no confidence in
the House of Commons if the conservative
party decides that Boris Johnson can
stay on As a caretaker now
that is really a a very very powerful
weapon but it in order to be successful
it would require a large number of
conservatives to vote with the
opposition parties or at the very least
to abstain in that vote of no confidence
if that vote of no confidence were to
pass the House of Commons the most
likely outcome would then be a general
election because the government would
have lost the confidence of Parliament
and in those circumstances and general
election would follow now kirst armor
like the other opposition parties says
that they would would want a general
election because it would give them the
opposite the opportunity to get rid of
this government but at the same time uh
a it may not necessarily be in their
interest to go to the country at the
moment and B they don't actually want to
plunge the country into the chaos of
having a general election particularly
when it be uncertain uh who was leading
the conservative party so he's got a
very difficult uh Road To Tread because
the only way he can express opposition
is by doing that and effectively but it
does have the risk of possibly ending up
in a general election now what's going
on at the moment is Boris Johnson has
still not publicly declared that he's
stepping down as prime minister and he
is using uh his uh guttering power to
act as a prime minister by pointing this
cabinet making it more difficult for the
transition period because people are
going to say well you know your
appointed by prime minister who then
said he's going to resign are you in
office and of course it already
raises a problem for the head of state
because you'll remember you'll know very
well that from those press releases we
get from Downing Street when their
ministerial changes it says the queen
has been pleased to appoint so and so in
this particular role well the Queen's
got to decide whether this is just
fantasy cabinets now being played by
Boris Johnson or whether it's something
that she should endorse particularly
since he says he's going but he hasn't
gone yet so he's just creating more and
more chaos and mess against the national
interest
Adam Bolton thank you very much uh
indeed the queen deciding whether or not
they are playing fantasy cabinets
according to Adam Bolton well in the
meantime those appointments are now
being confirmed as I've just went to
Beth Rigby broke just a few uh moments
ago we are now being told that Greg
Clarke is the new leveling up secretary
that now being officially confirmed by
number 10 so it seems as though the
prime minister is pushing ahead he is
trying to reform his government which
would allow him a few more months in
office until Autumn until the time when
the new leader of the conservative party
is appointed we're expecting that
resignation statement from Boris Johnson
in number 10 probably around lunchtime
that the ladies have been hearing though
of course on these days things are
always somewhat of a Movable Feast and
it does feel as though those
appointments are now it's starting to be
confirmed will he find enough people who
are willing to serve under him as he
tries to stay on As a caretaker leader
in the months ahead
ahead or we can discuss some of those
issues in a bit more detail we're joined
now from Kent by the former conservative
advisor Claire Pearsall and also from
Bahrain the former labor advisor and
Economist James Medway thank you both
for being with us Claire to you first do
you think that Boris Johnson should be
able to stay on as prime minister
no I don't I think that we are in a
really precarious position and by him
sort of holding on with the tips of his
fingers to a job that he really should
no longer have it's just going to cause
more chaos and I think Adam laid it out
really really clearly just now by saying
he's making it worse by appointing some
kind of assembled cabinet and at the
moment we've only seen one position
being filled and bear in mind pretty
much every single government department
has substantial losses I'm not sure he's
going to find the rest of the cabinet
members very easily I I just think he
needs to make his statement I think he
needs to go and we need to be able to
move on from this very very quickly
uh okay well let's go across to James
Medway uh shall we a former labor
advisor to the Charlie Chancellor then
Charlie Chancellor uh John and McDonald
do you think that the Prime Minister
should be able to stay on do I guess the
argument from number 10 would be to give
that continuity and to allow him to
really push ahead with some of the
reforms at this important time
no I mean there's going to be an
agreement on this no he certainly should
not stay on but also I mean he shouldn't
have been there in the first place uh
anybody who's worked with him there was
a article from Max Hastings doing the
rounds this morning from three years ago
his first editor saying that Boris
Johnson's essentially a Serial liar not
to be trusted not someone who should be
in a position of responsibility he
should never have been there in the
first place the conservative party
should never appointed him there
shouldn't have been uh the belief I'm
just going to come in if I'm
particularly 2019.
I'm just going to come if I may you said
that he should never been there in the
first place I mean he won an election
didn't he he was elected with a very
substantial majority so I don't really
understand what you're saying if he
should never have been there in the
first place now look this is me giving
my uh straight down the line political
views and this I don't agree with Boris
Johnson I don't think he should have
been prime minister I would preferred if
he didn't win the general election I
would have preferred
to have to break you off again apologies
it's one of those very fast-moving uh
mornings because we're hearing that
James cleverley has now been appointed
as the Secretary of State for Education
you can see there the official
announcement from 10 Downing Street on
Twitter James cleverly at the new
secretary of state for Education the
third Secretary of State for education
in as many days astonishingly and let's
bring in our political editor Beth Rigby
those appointments are now starting to
roll in now aren't they yes they are and
now so I'm just checking my phone
because yes James Cleveland just
officially confirmed I've also been told
that Rob Buckland the former Justice
secretary who was shuffled out in the
last reshuffle by Boris Johnson and he
was if you like the last stand-in man of
the one nation uh horse of the
conservative party still in his cabinet
I'm told that he is going to be the
Welsh secretary so he is replacing Simon
Hart so we have James cleverley
education secretary Robert Buckland I
think will be announced soon as the
Welsh secretary and who was the final
one that we did uh Greg Clark Greg Clark
as the new leveling up secretary
um so and it's interesting James
cleverley is a long-term Ally of Boris
Johnson's as well he's been very close
to him he was demoted by Boris Johnson
as well but he now back uh in the
cabinet so that's three uh cabinet
appointments Clark's leveling up
Buckland which hasn't been announced yet
but respected wealth secretary and
cleverly to education and how much
um do you think that this is Shoring up
Boris Johnson's position in the months
ahead because obviously you know talking
to Adam talking to many of our guests
this morning as well they're saying that
it's gonna be difficult for him to stay
on until the autumn
how important is it for his survival
until the Autumn to get somebody's posts
I really think that there's a more
pressing issue than all of the politics
around this at the moment which is
cabinet posts need fill in because the
Department of Education needs to be run
for a star you know our kids go to
school and those departments need
secretaries of state that are
accountable so actually you could argue
it the other way which is Boris Johnson
feels as still the Prime Minister that
it's his duty to fill those posts
another although I guess if he did if he
did step down and allow Dominic RAV to
take over or whoever it would be Theresa
May then that could be done as well yeah
and and what's happening now is we we've
talked about is within the party there
is a division about whether Boris
Johnson should be allowed to stay on uh
until October or September when the new
leader is announced or whether he should
leave now but in the interim he is
appointing people into a cabinet and he
and he wants to fill those posts okay
thank you very much Beth always
interesting to talk so three uh
positions there we understand being
filled so far Greg Clark leveling up
James cleverley to education and Beth
just hearing their uh Robert Butler and
also being brought back into the fold
well let's bring this back in Adam
Bolton at shall we the former Sky News
physical editor and presenter Beth just
making the point there that perhaps the
most pressing issue of all is to get
these departments up and running as soon
as possible department for education for
example or almost left completely bereft
not only of a second state Secretary of
State but also ministers too
well it's certainly true that normal
government business has grown to a halt
that Parliament has been unable to do
its normal committee and consideration
of bills because uh this Boris Johnson
has been unable to field uh ministers
and so there'd have to be a lot of
cancellations it's also true that for
example we've heard from Ben Wallace
currently uh The Bookies favorite to be
the next leader of the conservative
party but he has only stayed on as
defense secretary because uh he needs to
do uh the uh the job just like Zoella
bravman the attorney general has said
that even although they think Boris
Johnson should go but bearing that in
mind appointments by Boris Johnson who's
already signaled he's going I'm just not
sure legally how binding uh the status
of these cabinet appointments is or
whether they will hold and as I say that
that simply creates uh more damage and
it may be e that Boris Johnson is making
these appointments as his last Act of
prime minister and then he is going to
leave the stage all together but it's
equally likely that possibly what he's
trying to do is to appoint a cabinet
which will be loyal to him uh through uh
what he hopes will be a lengthy
transition period perhaps hoping that at
the end of that he can somehow cling on
to office it's a really really dangerous
time for the British constitution and
British political governments
okay Adam thank you very much uh indeed
Adam Bolton there uh for us well let's
go now to Parliament Central Lobby
always at the Hub I guess in Westminster
where there was a steady flow of MPS we
can talk now to uh Deputy political
editor Sam Cote Sam who you've been
talking to
you and Bell now Aaron is one of the was
one of the first people to come out
against Boris Johnson back in January uh
possibly feeling somewhat Vindicated by
where so many colleagues are today and
he joins me now to digest some of the
huge amounts of news we've had this
morning
where are we now we have some of your
colleagues going back into government to
prop up Boris Johnson's regime Boris
Johnson wanting to go on maybe as long
as October does any of that feel
sustainable morning Sam my preference I
think would be to have a caretaker
Premiership if Dominic Raab is not
running for the leadership and that's my
understanding but it might not be
correct uh he did a very good job while
Boris was incapacitated with kovid and I
think that's what we need right now we
need a period of calm
um you know I have all the time in the
world for the colleagues who've just
gone back into government they're all
decent people who are serving their
country and as are some of the people
who haven't resigned from government
they're there because people need to do
those jobs like defense secretary Like
Home Secretary but my preference would
be that we have a caretaker prime
minister for the summer why why do you
think Boris Johnson needs to go now well
I'm concerned as I said in the house
this morning that he won't be able to
feel all the ministerial positions and I
think it's important that we have all
those ministerial positions there I also
think the last 48 hours his refusal to
accept reality has done a lot of damage
um to trust in the institution as a
whole in in Parliament in the
conventions that we have in the
conservative party that when the game's
up the game's up and unfortunately it
took a long time for the prime minister
to realize that I'm glad he's come to a
census today I think it's quite sad I
backed Boris Johnson in the first place
I voted leave he's delivered a lot for
the country he'd done a huge job on
Ukraine even in the last few months
while I've been opposing him I think
it's a sad day but I think it would be
better for the country if we had a
caretaker prime minister isn't it quite
incredible that today the day where
Boris Johnson in the next few hours is
going to announce he's leaving office
there's yet another battle to pull him
out of office uh not at the time of his
cheesing what damage what decisions are
you worried that Boris Johnson might
make if he is allowed to stay in place
until October
um I think it's a question propriety he
has lost the confidence of the party
that's absolutely apparent and therefore
it's not appropriate that we have
anything other than a proper caretaker
Administration now if we remember in the
final days of the Theresa May
Administration she made huge commitments
she put us on the path zero without any
parliamentary vote and you know I
support the the aim of getting towards
net zero but there was no scrutiny of
that that was a last minute decision
something similar like that could happen
uh under any Administration I think you
needed a definite caretaker and I also
can't see why it needs to take till
October anyway we you know assuming
Boris Johnson's resigning as we expect
this afternoon we will I'm sure we can
complete the Parliamentary process to
get down to two candidates before recess
and then the leadership going out to the
party in the country should be quicker
than before because we now have
centralized membership records so it
shouldn't take as long to organize the
ballot as it did uh when Boris Johnson
took over how can you get Boris Johnson
out sooner than he wants to go What
mechanisms do you have what techniques I
mean could we end up with the people
like James cleverley and Greg Clark
going back into government being urged
by people like you to resign against
um look I think it has to be somewhat
informal it has to be
we've seen the the shortcomings of that
approach in the last 48 hours I'll
concede but you know the mood of the
party uh conveyed through the 1922
committee and obviously we've got
elections for that on Monday which I'll
be standing in by the way running
running for the executive I I do think
that's my preference now if it's not
possible then it's not possible I mean
I'm not saying it's absolutely essential
but my preference would be to have a
caretaker prime minister thank you very
much indeed that is where we are in the
conservative party Boris Johnson about
to resign already the next conversation
about when he'll actually leave firmly
underway Sophie
yeah it certainly is firmly underway
isn't it sound well we're expecting
still that statement from Boris Johnson
announcing his intention to resign
around 1pm it seems to have been pushed
back slightly but um he's expected to be
out on the street shortly just to bring
him back very quickly since you're on it
I've just been told that he's going to
make the statement at 12 30 12 35
minutes the PM to make his statement
I've just been told that from someone in
his team there you go a bit of breaking
news for you from Beth South Africa
editor there at 30 minutes to go 35
minutes to go until that resignation
statement form from the Prime Minister
it's been a busy morning for him already
he's been filling some of those vacant
posts in his cabinet uh James cleverley
to education Malt House the chance of
the Dr Lancaster Greg Platt leveling up
Robert Buckland to Wells secretary will
it be enough for him to stay on in post
until the Autumn that is a big question
to be answered well we might get a bit
more of a flavor of that 12 30 when that
prime minister is expected the prime
minister is expected to give his
statements here in Downing Street
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Sky news's coverage live
from Downing Street where in the next
half an hour the prime minister is
expected to give a statement on this
street announcing his resignation at 12
30. we're expecting that statement from
the prime minister in the meantime he's
been busy filling at some of the vacant
roles that in his cabinet as he seeks to
buy a few more months in office before
standing aside to allow a new leader to
take his place well we're joined on the
street this morning by our political
editor Beth Ruby and Beth we're
expecting that statement aren't we in
around half an hour's time what kind of
tone do you think we might hear yeah so
we've just been told that we will get
that statement at 12 30 we thought it
was going to be at one o'clock it's now
at 12 30 and as for the tone I've been
told by some of the people that have
been around the prime minister in the
past 12 hours that he was very amicable
with cabinet ministers going in uh to
give him the bad news last night and
that he has been upbeat this morning so
let's see what tone he strikes knowing
Boris Johnson a bit having interviewed
him a few times and watched him impress
conferences and watched him at these big
moments I think he'll want to do two
things I think he'll want to view it as
an address to the nation like he did in
the pandemic so I think he will want to
be a statesmanlike but I also think he
will want to use it as an opportunity to
run through some of his Greatest Hits
he'll talk about a brexit he will talk I
have no doubt about the vaccine roller I
would put money on that actually so we
could do a wager later and I think he
will talk about the huge mandate that he
was given back in 2019 and and probably
he will talk about the regret that he
feels that he has to stand aside but
when I think back to the last time I was
here and it was Theresa May resigning
and she resigned and then Boris Johnson
came from the palace up the street it
was the most extraordinary of days and
she broke actually when she I remember
it very distantly she said it has been
the greatest privilege of my life to
serve the country I love and it's stuck
in my mind I didn't even have to check
it normally I have to check every quote
I forget them but but her voice
um broke as she said the country I love
and she went back in I I don't imagine
that I will see Boris Johnson shedding a
tear but he might find it a very
emotional moment you have to remember
Sophie he didn't want to go yeah this is
it isn't it he has been almost drowned
to this position and it has been right
at the last moment when he simply didn't
have a cabinet left and then I guess he
was forced to accept the inevitable it
was interesting hearing you talk about
the memories that you had I'm sorry I've
got a sorry I've got a break in line
here just to tell you that Kip mock
house as we were talking about earlier
the police and Minister has been
appointed the chancellor of the duchy of
Lancaster so he is going to the cabinet
office so that was the post uh Michael
Gove had it then he went to living up
then Steve Barkley had that position and
then he straddled that uh between
um the uh cabinet office and the chief
of staff anyway I've been told uh that
kit Malt House is going to be the chance
of the duchy of Lancaster uh there you
go the positions are starting to really
fill up their as you can say kit not has
John dushy blanchetta had at the
education secretary the wells Secretary
of State for Wales at a leveling up
secretary uh position filled a busy
morning for Boris Johnson yeah and the
the very excellent Steve swimford who's
the political coach of the times is also
reporting uh that there's going to be a
cabinet meeting apparently at 3 P.M I'm
just trying to get that confirmed but I
mean what an extraordinary day that we
have all of this and then Boris Johnson
holds a cabinet meeting with his new
cabinet I haven't got that confirmed I
should say but Steve swinford is
normally as you know on the money yeah
he certainly is and it does feel doesn't
it that if that is the case then he must
be pretty confident that he's going to
have a full cabinet buying 3 P.M
I mean Nadine says we publicly said to
the Prime Minister this morning you need
to go but he didn't actually resign and
still a Braverman as well yeah and that
happened actually
a few cabinet ministers you know um has
didn't resigned but he told him he had
to go uh Patel didn't resign but she
told him he had to go uh the dean Sahara
we publicly said he had to go uh Michael
Gove probably told him that he was going
to resign if he didn't go and Boris
Johnson sacked him before Michael Gove
got his moment to resign
um so so a number of them
um uh didn't resign but wanted him to go
so he's got Nadine zahari still in
posters Chancellor and now he's filled
those gaps so the Welsh secretary is
going to be Robert Buckland the leveling
up secretary that was Michael Gove is
going to be uh Greg Clark education
secretary is Michelle donalan she was
only just appointed and then she
resigned that's going to be his old Ally
James cleverley and we've just been told
Kip Moore house is going to be the duchy
of Lancaster yeah another older Ally for
the Prime Minister it's interesting as
well Beth isn't it I was just reflecting
when you were talking about the Theresa
May resignations statement and the
emotion that he felt there and you know
you kind of cast your mind further back
as well David Cameron who obviously
stepped aside after the referendum vote
Gordon Brown you know bringing his kind
of family out to join him as well and it
does you do get the sense don't you that
it could be a very different uh
statement from the Prime Minister who is
already appointing a new cabinet for him
to kind of push push ahead for the
months ahead well I think I think Boris
Johnson I mean David Cameron had to go
because he lost the referendum Theresa
May didn't want to go but she was forced
out not in a dissimilar way to what's
happening to Boris Johnson in that she
won a confidence vote but then there was
still agitation and six months later was
her moment when she got the tap on the
shoulder for sir gray and Brady and was
told that it was time for her to go and
she she just she just walked she didn't
have all the drama that Boris Johnson
has had
um but Boris Johnson now is in a similar
position the confidence though he won
but party was a movable his cabinet
telling him to go and he found himself
in a position where he's got to resign
as we've been talking there in the last
few minutes me and Beth there has been a
bit of movement on uh Downing Street
which is probably what you would expect
given it's now just to get the clock at
the bottom of the screen just over 20
minutes until the prime minister's
statement we've had people coming out
about number 10 and number 11. uh some
kind of wires cables some of the I guess
the kind of structures around the
statement being brought out so it does
feel that I mean the level of activity
here on Downing Street has always been a
pretty Lively uh this morning to say the
least but we're seeing a stepping up as
everyone on the street it starts to get
ready to hear what Boris Johnson does
have to say at 12 13 as Beth was just
saying you know the tone of it I think
would be very interesting indeed we know
who's going to resign we know he's going
to set a timetable for stepping down
it's the position that you didn't want
to be in but at the same time he is busy
appointing people to his cabinet we've
had appointments this morning the
reports from the times that there's
going to be cabinet meeting at 3 P.M so
lots of activity at going ahead let's
bring in Adam Bolton at this point shall
we the former at Sky News projector and
presenter and Adam Beth was just
reflecting on some of the statements
that we've heard over the years from
departing Prime Ministers how do you
think boss Johnson's speech will differ
from some of the other ones that you've
covered in your time I think we're going
to have to listen very carefully to what
Boris Johnson says not just for the
emotion of it but actually the content
what claims he makes about when he's
going to resign how long he plans to
carry on and also what this cabinet he's
now appointed really means and if he
comes out and he's tends to be defiant
in these circumstances we saw him
yesterday at the liaison committee and
says that he's going to govern strongly
as long as there's he's there As a
caretaker I think that will be very
controversial and it's not sure it's
going to stand there are two theories
really about what's going on with the
appointment of the cabinet one is spite
to keep out the resignees the other is
that he's appointing a moderate
transition cabinet but we can go now to
the institute for government where
Theresa May is giving the brokenshire
lecture on political governance be very
interesting to hear what the former
prime minister has to say and I would
also like to thank Kathy brokenshire
Jeremy white Chloe Smith and the
institute for government for the work in
establishing the lecture it is I believe
a fitting and Lasting Memorial to James
who was not just a valued and trusted
colleague but also a wonderful friend
and I can think of no better place to to
give this lecture than here at the
institute for government
this is an organization dedicated to
making government more effective
dare I say it
Effective Government needs effective
ministers
and I can think of no more effective
Minister than the late James brokenshire
James joins the home office as one of my
junior ministers already highly
knowledgeable on home Affairs having
shadowed the brief for four years
he served first as parliamentary under
Secretary of State for Crime reduction
then for crime and security then as
minister of estate for boat of State for
both security and immigration grappling
at once with two of the most important
and complex areas of policy in fact I
recall the then permanent secretary
remarking as James was responsible for
two-thirds of Home Office business what
on Earth were the other ministers going
to do
on becoming prime minister I appointed
James to the cabinet as Secretary of
State for Northern Ireland and
subsequently as Secretary of State for
housing communities and local government
and he was of course later reappointed
to the home office as minister of State
for security under the new government
James was respected by all those he
worked with and civil servants liked
working with him
he took the time to understand the
issues thought carefully about them and
would challenge officials when necessary
but they always knew that the challenge
came because he wanted the policy to
work he wanted government to be
effective
he was always respectful of officials
understanding that good government
requires politicians and civil servants
to work together as a team everyone
determined to provide the best practical
solution for the public we all serve
when thinking about James and why he was
so effective three elements come to mind
and it's these three that I want to
develop in this lecture as I address
this issue of restoring faith in
politics
and those three elements are firstly
that he was a good constituency MP
recognizing that it is in the
constituency that we can see the impact
of policy
secondly James respected Parliament
understanding the importance of the
scrutiny that Parliament provides
he accepted both that Parliament can
improve legislation and that sometimes
there has to be compromise in order to
get legislation through
another element of this was his
willingness to work across the house to
find Solutions
this came most naturally in relation to
his work as security minister but in
other areas too he would take the time
and trouble to speak to his opposite
numbers
and thirdly he knew that ministers have
to get to grips with the issues
it isn't good enough just to wing it or
prioritize getting the headlines an
effective Minister takes the time and
trouble to really get into the detail of
the issue
James was a Dependable safe Pair of
Hands and I always had confidence in him
but when I look back at the sort of man
he was James wasn't merely competent
he was unmistakably somebody with deep
rooted values
he exemplified decency honesty and
integrity
values that I believe are essential in
public life if we are to have faith in
our politics
as was remarked at his memorial service
James came into politics to serve not to
be served
I have said before that Parliament is
the worst off without James
I would also say that our politics and
Parliament would be more likely to be
trusted by the public if there were more
politicians who clearly showed they
shared James's values
public service was perhaps James's
strongest motivation
he was a consummate Member of Parliament
he knew that his increasingly successful
ministerial career was only possible
because his constituents had sent him to
Parliament on their behalf
and he didn't just represent their views
he was deeply embedded within the local
community
he brought people together and threw
service to his constituents earned their
respect
in our modern representative democracy
it's no longer enough simply to turn up
at Parliament and shuffle through the
voting lobbies
the public rightly expect us to be
fighting their Corner taking up their
concerns visible in the community and
working for them on local issues and
interests
they expect us to be making a tangible
difference to their everyday lives
this was a concept often misunderstood
by fellow ministers internationally
I particularly remember one of my
opposite numbers when I was home
secretary remarking on the peculiar
arrangement in the UK of being both a
minister and an MP and asking what it
was like
I replied put it this way today I am at
this International Summit discussing
counter-terrorism tomorrow I will open a
community vegetable garden
while these seemingly frivolous
constituency engagements might not have
the glamor of international Summits
they've always been just as important to
me and I know that was a view shared by
James brokenshire too
I spoke on my last appearance at the
dispatch box as prime minister about the
vital link between every single member
of the House and the constituencies we
represent
I called it the Bedrock of our
parliamentary democracy and our Liberty
because without strong relationships
with the communities we serve how can we
expect to build faith in our politics as
a whole
the strong relationship James had with
his local community is particularly
inspiring at a time when trusting
politicians has been eroded
a recent hugov poll for the ippr found
that 63 percent of people believe their
politicians are nearly out for
themselves
more shockingly five percent just one in
20 people believe that MPS are in it for
the interests of their country
a recent poll for Carnegie UK found that
over three quarters of the population
don't trust MPS very much or at all
now distrust in politics is not a new
issue we were asking the same questions
of the public 80 years ago the
difference is when asked in 1944 just 35
percent of the population agreed that
politicians were out for themselves
compared to two-thirds of people today
the Carnegie survey also identified nine
values often thought of as being
desirable in public life and asked
people which they felt was most
important
almost half of the representative sample
chose honesty and integrity
by contrast fewer than five percent of
people prioritized other values
including individual liberty and
strength and security
of those who most valued honesty and
integrity
only eight percent agreed the government
has this value
the figures make for sobering reading
but they demonstrate that if we are to
accommodate voters priorities we ought
to be placing at least as much if not
more emphasis on improving honesty and
integrity in public Life as we do in
other areas of public policy
those of us engaged in politics must
grasp just how significantly the
electorate feel their expectations are
not being met
one of the fundamental expectations of
the people we represent is that we play
by the rules no double standards no
taking advantage of the position one
holds is that inherently British sense
of fair play
originally popularized of course through
our nation's greatest sport cricket
a game that in a time of Empire
inequality and class divide brought
together Aristocrats and laborers on an
equal footing under one set of rules
in qriket it's not enough to avoid
breaking the rules in fact the game
requires adherence to its Traditions as
much as its laws
law 41
the captains are responsible for
ensuring that players conducted within
the spirit of cricket as well as within
the laws
respect is essential respect of one's
teammates the opposition and the
authority of the Umpire
and players must create a positive
Atmosphere by their own conduct and
encourage others to do likewise
for any action which is seen to abuse
this Spirit causes injury to the game
itself
I take the same view of politics
Breaking the Rules and Breaking the
spirit of the rules causes injury to the
standing of our democracy
in politics of course playing by the
rules means following the law and it's
not unreasonable to expect those of us
who write the law of the land to follow
its letter and spirit
it also means adhering to the rule of
law the doctoring the door people and
institutions including the state itself
are accountable under the law as it
stands
it protects the liberty of the
individual against the arbitrary use of
power
it underpins political and economic
stability and are standing in the wider
world
and as I've said before we cannot claim
as a country to operate in line with the
rule of law if we flagrantly abuse our
own obligations under treaties we have
signed
playing by the rules also means not
changing them on a whim to suit
short-term or personal interests
the government's decision back in
November to attempt to change the rules
on parliamentary standards was
ill-judged and wrong
it is right the ministers have since
apologized but the episode did little to
improve faith in our politics and
spelled the beginning of an unhappy
period for the government and for our
public life
playing by the rules means following not
because you have to but because you do
so willingly recognizing that the damage
from breaking them may not be direct or
immediate but it can be severe and
Lasting
it's a spirit of cricket again
it's especially pertinent in our
constitutional system where adherence to
convention is an important element of
our democracy
the flexibility afforded by our
uncodified constitution has served us
well over centuries
by and large its slow Evolution has
enabled it to meet the requirements of
the day where other countries have found
themselves caught in a legal straight
jacket
but our system only works if conventions
are not cast aside wholesale or at least
not willfully misinterpreted
it rests on those in positions of
authority being trusted to uphold the
values and traditions of our public life
now of course in our parliamentary
system the role that exemplifies that
the most is the Speaker of the House of
Commons
the one person above all others who is
expected to be neutral in their work
the Practical exercisable power held by
the speaker to shape public debate and
the work of our legislature is often
under-reported
the workings of the house are determined
officially by the standing orders
but the interpretation and application
of those orders is entirely within the
hands of the speaker
in areas where the standing orders are
not clear we consult works of
authorities such as Erskine May and
adhere to proven historical conventions
long-standing practices like the
government of the day determining the
business of the house or the proper use
of a humble address which until 2017 had
not been used substantively since 1866.
on that occasion 2017
the labor party leadership sought to
disregard the long-standing conventions
of our legislature for short-term
political gain
in doing so breaking another of our most
fundamental practices in not seeking to
involve the Monarch in our political
debate
if we depart from the spirit of our
established constitutional rules to suit
short-term interests we undermine faith
in our system
another well-known Convention of the
House of Commons of course is the way we
refer to fellow parliamentarians we are
all in the house at least honorable
members convention dictates that we
don't address one another instead pose
our questions and responses to the chair
convention prevents us from calling one
of the another liars and traitors
for over 150 years these practices
admittedly perhaps odd sounding to the
outside world have helped make the cut
and thrust of debate less personal and
direct and have helped in a small way to
maintain the Dignity of the house and
the honor of its members
because politics is an honorable Pursuit
and in my experience of over 30 years in
public life
the vast majority of those who seek
political office are motivated to
improve the lives of others and fight
for what they believe to be
Theresa May they're speaking at The
Institute for a government you can see
there let me just get out of the way of
the picture you can see there the uh
the podium in front of the door of
number 10 outside number 11
staff serving the Prime Minister have
been Gathering waiting to hear the
statement that we're expecting in the
next 10 minutes or so Andrew Griffith
for example we can see standing there
the prime minister's director of policy
and other members of the staff standing
outside at number 11 Gathering and to
hear the resignation statement of the
Prime Minister expected at 12 30.
they're currently plugging in the podium
outside number 10. traditionally happens
when a prime minister stands down you
can see on your screen there's James
dodridge in the middle of the great
polyte so his right is Andrew Griffiths
he was the prime minister's policy Chief
used to be the Chief Financial Officer
actually at Sky PLC behind Andrew behind
Andrew Griffith you can see gito Hari
he's the prime minister's director of
communications and I'm wondering too
whether Carrie Johnson might come out I
remember when the Prime Minister was
appointed to the post that she stood
there with members and staff if we look
down the other side of the street I
don't think you can see this but there
are MPS also Gathering now I don't know
if we can flip the camera around but
um that I can see Connor Burns one of
the prime minister's oldest allies I
don't know if you can see there's people
in the way but yes there you go you can
see Robert pesterner an ITV all the
cruise Long Street but you can see the
uh minus uh MPS and there was some talk
this morning
um that the number 10 team had asked for
MPS uh to come to come behind Boris
Johnson uh when he comes out and and
some of them are gathering they're not a
huge group I have to say but no they all
are I think that's is that Heather
wheeler at the front so in the white
jacket embracing some of her colleagues
so embracing some people yeah as you say
Johnny Mercer I can also just Glimpse
behind that there's Alan Mack there who
is I think a whip
um I don't know all of their names
actually but there you've got Daniel
karinsky and Peter Brown also there as
you say there not perhaps the largest
grouping of MPS ever but certainly it
doesn't feel like that edict has gone
out from number 10 there's more
supportive MPS should come to the
streets ready to hear the Prime Minister
statement so what we have uh here is
outside the door of number 11 the
members of staff at number 10 and number
11 and coming out to here and the other
end of the street is the Gathering of
MPS as well so everyone really getting
ready here the last check's been made to
the podium
they are making those white getting
those wires ready
from Boris Johnson it's a speech that
you didn't want to have to make we are
expecting him to come out of that door
shortly to give the resignation
statement that he has been resisting for
the last few days but it will be we
expect so different in tone to Res
explanation speeches of the past Tim's
determined to keep going on in the role
as the kind of parent-taking leader if
you like after setting out a timetable
for his resignation for some months
until the order I'm sorry until the next
person is appointed back if you just if
you just can pan over to uh to there's
sorry there's just been a run of new
people now coming out all of the number
10 teams now coming out filling up the
street and I can see the uh his
Communications team says Rosie Bates
Williams there's Steph Liz uh you can
see if you move to number 11 sorry yeah
at the end you can see now uh his comms
team have come out all his senior
members of Staff uh they're now waiting
and you can see the street has removed
from the the lady in the floor just
slide behind Simone Finn baroness Finn
one of his key advisors and was once
actually an advisor to remember to
Michael Gove as she's there one of his I
think she's a deputy chief of staff so
the Boris Johnson's team now all out
there as we await for the Prime Minister
and I have to say though in terms of the
appeal to get MPS out there's not a
massive group of MPS there is there
there is it exactly and I think we
should be able to hopefully have a look
at some of the MPS who are gathered
there and as you say Beth to be honest
if it is true which it seems like it was
uh the number at 10 have um have made
the appeal for MPS to so I can't
remember trying to get uh to have a look
at the MPS who have gathered I was Beth
was just saying as number 10 made the
appeal for the support of MPS to come to
the street to show their support for
Boris Johnson that is not a great number
of MPS who have actually uh onto that uh
call a few people that we've managed to
spot Connor Burns Alan Mack Heather
wheeler Peter bone Daniel karinsky but
clearly that is not a huge number of MPS
and perhaps suggesting there that even
though the MPS have uh answer Boris
Johnson's caller in he has managed to
refill hey guys happy with the audio one
two three four five six good stuff
I mean looking at that I don't know how
many how many MPS would you say there
Thursday
I mean for a prime minister that two and
a half years ago won a majority of 80
the most successful
conservative leader at The Ballot Box
since Margaret Thatcher totally crushing
uh David Cameron at The Ballot Box at
least and and really that isn't a
massive group of MPS uh here today given
uh how many uh seats to him back in 2019
but I think it reflects Sophie the
bitterness between this prime minister
and his parliamentary party I was saying
yesterday in in the comments it was
visceral it was vicious it gets like
that towards the end because for Boris
Johnson he was in the fight for his
political life and when you get to the
end game like that it gets nasty and and
it really did deteriorate the atmosphere
and obviously a number of MPS have
thought no I'm not going to come along
and stand behind you I think the MPS
might be standing behind come and stand
behind him I guess he would like that as
a show of strength but let's see see
what they do it's interesting isn't it
though because if it is and tenders the
show's strength which you have to assume
it is
you can only must drop about 30 MPS you
do have to wonder if that was perhaps
the show's Transit was attended Jacob
Bridge morgue and Johnny At Mercer
so if you move back I'm sorry the poor
cameraman
can you move we're trying to show you
sorry let me let me talk to you about it
as the camera rolls over now
number 11.
one of the prime minister's key
lieutenants there he is you can see him
he's come out of speakers
as well
and the baby um
her nine month old they just came on the
trip to Chong with us actually it was
lovely I I got a little sight of that
lovely baby there is Carrie Johnson and
next to her Nadine Doris uh the prime
minister's closest Ally and look there's
the little baby and I don't know where
wolf is they've got a toddler I mean
it's probably quite risky having a
toddler out on the dance well the
toddler did not come on the trip which
um as anyone knows who takes a toddler
on a plane is probably best advised yeah
so look there we have it proceeding
Paris first Harry
Potter wave she looks actually lovely
doesn't she
dress and the little Baby Ronnie there
she is she's sweet little baby she's
only nine months old
um and her Dean Doris and we are waiting
for the Prime Minister uh the door is
opening here he comes let's listen in
afternoon everybody good afternoon
everybody
good afternoon
thank you thank you
it is clearly now the will of the
Parliamentary conservative party that
there should be a new leader of that
party and therefore a new prime minister
and I've agreed with sir Graham Brady
the chairman of our back bench MPS that
the process of choosing that new leader
should begin now and the timetable will
be announced next week and I've today
appointed a cabinet to serve as I will
until a new leader is in place
so I want to say to the millions of
people who voted for us in 2019 many of
them voting conservative for the first
time thank you for that incredible
mandate the biggest conservative
majority since 1987 the biggest share of
the vote since 1979.
and the reason I have fought so hard in
the last few days to continue to deliver
that mandate in person was not just
because I wanted to do so but because I
felt it was my job
my duty my obligation to you to continue
to do what we promised in 2019
and of course I'm immensely proud of the
achievements of this government from
getting brexit done to settling our
relations uh with the continent for over
half a century reclaiming the power for
this country to make its own laws in
Parliament getting us all through the
pandemic delivering the fastest vaccine
rollout in Europe the fastest exit from
Lockdown and in the last few months
leading the West in standing up to
Putin's aggression in Ukraine
and let me say no to the people of
Ukraine that I know that we in the UK
will continue to back your fight for
freedom for as long as it takes and at
the same time in this country we've been
pushing forward a vast program of
investment in infrastructure and skills
and Technology the biggest in a century
because if I have one insight into human
beings it is the genius and talent and
enthusiasm and Imagination are evenly
distributed throughout the population
but opportunity is not and that's why we
must keep leveling up keep unleashing
the potential of every part of the
United Kingdom and if we can do that in
this country we will be the most
prosperous in Europe
and in the last few days I've tried to
persuade my colleagues that it would be
eccentric to change governments when
we're delivering so much and when we
have such a vast mandate and when we're
actually only a handful of points behind
in the polls even in midterm after quite
a few months of pretty Relentless
sledging and when
the economic scene is so difficult
domestically and internationally and I
regret and not to have been successful
in those arguments and of course it's
painful and not to be able to see
through so many ideas and and projects
myself but as we've seen at Westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves and my friends in
politics no one is remotely
indispensable and our brilliant and
darwinian system will produce another
leader equally committed to taking this
country forward through tough times not
just helping families to get through it
but changing and improving the way we do
things cutting burdens on businesses and
families and yes cutting taxes because
that is the way to generate the growth
and the income we need to pay for great
Public Services
and to that new leader I say whoever he
or she may be I say I will give you as
much support as I can
and to you the British public
I know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and uh perhaps quite a few who will also
be disappointed
and I want you to know how sad I am to
be giving up the best job in the world
that thems the breaks
I want to thank Carrie and our children
to all members of my family who've had
to put up with so much for so long
I want to thank the Peerless British
civil service for all the help and
support that you have given our police
our emergency services and of course our
fantastic NHS who at critical moment
helped to extend my own period in office
as well as our armed services and our
agencies that are so admired around the
world
and our indefatigable conservative party
members and supporters whose selfless
campaigning makes our democracy possible
I want to thank the wonderful staff here
at Checkers uh to hear number 10 and of
course at Checkers and our fantastic
prop Force detectives the one group by
the way who never leak
above all I want to thank
you the British public
for the immense privilege that you have
given me
and I want you to know that from now on
until the new prime minister is in place
your interests will be served
and the government of the country
will be carried on
being prime minister
is an education in itself
I've traveled to every part of the
United Kingdom and in addition to the
beauty of our natural world I found so
many people possessed of such boundless
British originality and so willing to
tackle old problems in new ways that I
know that even if things can sometimes
seem dark now
our future together is golden
thank you all very much
thank you
Boris Johnson uh they're talking about
how sad he is to give up the best job in
the world that thems the brakes thank
you for an incredible mandate she said
to the people who gave him uh the
Mandate of that 2019 general election uh
Victory but the darwinian system he said
will now produce a new leader let's go
to uh Beth Rigby at shall we Beth what
would you make of that statement well it
was It was kind of trademark but it was
vintage Boris Johnson wasn't it uh it
was as I thought it would be he was
talking about his greatest hits that had
some humor in there it was
teamers and it was also very dignified
actually
um a very dignified speech I thought in
which he uh held his head high he
accepted that he didn't want to leave
and he gave or one thing about Rose
Johnson is he doesn't really give you
much emotion but but there what he does
is he uses language to show the emotion
and some of the things that you know uh
struck me he said of course it was
painful not to be able to see through
the projects and as I said before he
rolled out the greatest hits he said how
proud he was to have got brexit done and
to put he said and to give the country
back the power to make its own laws
that's how he put it he talked about
leveling up we must keep on leveling up
and we must fight for the freedom of
Ukraine for as long as it takes he then
went on to say of course it is painful
not to see the projects through that I
wanted to and then he said in a
characteristically humorous way he said
but the herd has moved and when the herd
all moves it moves quickly and then he
said no one is remotely
indispensable he'd said how much he
wanted
to stay on and then he said that the
darwinian system as he put it will
produce another leader who he said he
would give as much support as he could
and then he touched upon his
divisiveness because he's battered it
off all the time but he said I know that
some of you many of you he said will be
relieved and some disappointed by my
resignation and he said he was so sad to
believe in the best job in the world as
he described it and then he finished off
by thanking the public for giving him as
he said the immense privilege of being
able to serve as the Prime Minister he
said being prime minister is an
education in itself and he said about
the boundless British energy and
enthusiasm that he had met around the
country and then he finally ended uh
with you know he is a journalist he's a
good writer and he does good oratory he
said it might feel dark now but the
future together is golden and with that
the Applause there were no tears a
massive Applause and he went back and he
also thanked his wife Harry Johnson who
was watching on with a nine month old
baby Romney oh yeah it was I thought
Beth it was interesting talking
beforehand about the emotion of other
resignation states that we've seen and
in recent days we've been told that
Boris Johnson is in buoyant spirits and
you know there were no tears obviously
from the Prime Minister but I did get a
sense we got a flicker of emotion from
him perhaps more than he usually shows
when he was talking about how sad he was
to go out the best job in the world as
she was saying talking quite frankly
about the reason that he's continued to
fight on so long perhaps a little bit of
an acknowledgment that he has been
trying to hang on to the job until it
just became impossible yeah and you know
and and he talked about you know he
started off by thanking the British
report for that huge mandate he wanted
it to be known that he was a winner once
and he won the biggest majority since
Margaret Thatcher and he wanted to
remind everyone of that and he explained
that that was the reason that he clung
on for so long that he felt that he have
been given a mandate by the people and
that mandate he felt stood but he said
as he acknowledged the hard moved
against him and once that happened there
really was nowhere else for him to go
but you know I didn't expect to see
Boris Johnson shed a tear the most
emotion I've ever seen in Boris Johnson
is him drop he'd drop sometimes drops
his head but he wanted that to be a
moment where he projected confidence and
optimism they are the tickets if you
like that attracted the public to him in
the first place the can-do optimism the
Boris Johnson boosterism as we used to
call it and and really that that speech
I think had bucket loads of that in
terms of the delivery but also look it's
hard to hear any prime minister talk
about having to leave that job it was
hard to hear David Cameron do it Theresa
May Boris Johnson because you know as he
said it's best job in the world I'm sad
to leave it I didn't want to go but I
had to leave and that must be absolutely
brutal to have to do that in the moment
but you know he was very composed he was
upbeat and like I did as I said I felt
that was vintage Boris Johnson he gave
us his best version of himself there
yeah certainly you can see uh around us
they are literally packing up at our
feet
I mean this is the brutality of politics
I think you know it can't prepare for
the big moment for the camera you can
see very quickly things are getting uh
yeah they're the guys so all the cables
were running along here and now it's all
been packed up yeah certainly thank you
so much for your analysis uh Beth Beth
Ricky there political editor well that
is it we hear of course the speech from
uh Boris Johnson a resignation speech
where he spoke about his when run
through his greatest hit that of course
a big majority but also expressed his
frustration in not being able to really
follow through on some of the Mandate
that he was given in terms of big
policies we can bring in Adam Bolton now
the former Sky News president and
presenter to discuss a bit of that and I
did I don't know if you agree Adam
detect a tinge of regret in the Boris
Johnson speech saying he must we must
keep leveling up but it was frustrating
not to be able to continue in the work
that he'd started and it really has been
a Premiership marked by outside events
covet the war in Ukraine do you think
that will be a sense something that
Boris Johnson I guess will regret
looking back on his legacy well I'll
leave aside the emotion if I may the
fact is this is a massive political
humiliation for Boris Johnson
who won a uh great general election
Victory or LED his party to a great
general election Victory but as he
admitted lost the confidence of his his
own party within the space of two years
since that general election I think
what's more important really is trying
to work out what's going to happen now
Boris Johnson I didn't actually use the
words I resign but he's clearly on the
way out and let's look at his words he
said uh I have today appointed a cabinet
to serve as I will until a new leader is
in place and he also said that the
Parliamentary party the 1922 committee
will announce a timetable next week now
that holds open the possibility that if
they go through the full leadership
election process of MPS choosing two
candidates and then those candidates
being voted on by the conservative party
that he could actually have quite a long
caretaker period as he sees it of course
the alternative and maybe he's put the
ball back in the into the Parliamentary
party is that they the MPS here come up
with one candidate uh who would
effectively take over before the end of
the month now we saw this before uh with
the transition to Theresa May and in
opposition to Michael Howard now if uh
that happens uh then we could have a
very very short transition period for
both Mr Johnson and this cabinet but
again uh he's not making it easy uh
easier for anyone else uh yeah I mean
he's been in office he highlighted the
things uh that happened in office uh
there will be disputes as to how well
the government handled the covid crisis
for example there will be disputes about
whether brexit has indeed been done and
there will also be uh disagreements uh
as to whether in other areas of policy
Mr Johnson has achieved very much at all
but the fact of the matter is uh he is
now out he will be going at the very
latest by this October and the next
party conference and as he not Powell
famously said all political careers end
in failure
they do don't make Adam
thank you very much
Johnson it has set out a timetable for
resigning as the leader of the
conservative party and also as prime
minister I guess the question of course
many are asking is whether or not he can
continue until at the Autumn we've seen
Liz Trust on Twitter in the last few
moments saying the prime minister's made
the right decision the government under
boris's leadership had many achievements
delivering brexit vaccines and back in
Ukraine we need calmness and unity now
she says and to keep governing that's
the critical bit while a new leader is
found and meanwhile another MP texts me
to say he's just tried to Gaslight the
party up to narcissism to the end so I
think that certainly gives you a bit of
a sense of the range of reactions of MPS
to that speech by Boris Johnson and
potential difficulties I guess in
uniting the party even in the month
ahead well let's bring in our Deputy
political editor now at shall we some
cases in Parliament says Central Lobby
Islam we've been talking to MPS what's
the reaction
thank you
that's right Sophie so yes a very
striking very important moment
constitutional moment Boris Johnson
signals that he will stand down but only
when there is a new conservative party
leader to take over from him an interim
cabinet as it were will Steward the
country up until that point what do MPS
make of it will that position hold well
let's get the first reaction from maturi
mpm by Jonathan gullis who uh called for
Boris Johnson to go a couple of days ago
having previously been a stunt supporter
what do you make of the speech thought
it was moving it was difficult to watch
to be honest with you Sam look I was as
you say up until recently I've been very
loyal to the Prime Minister because I
believe he is instinctively a good man
and I'm grateful for all he did for
Stoke on Trent with the 56 million for
the leveling up fund 17.6 million kids
growth Town deal 31 minutes bus back
better and 500 new home office jobs this
is a man who understood West Oak on
Trent North kids grab and talk was it's
where he's invested it's where he's made
sure that he delivered on that brexit uh
you know delay that had been happening
so it was it was difficult to see but I
sadly engaged the conclusion as you say
a number of days ago that this simply
was untenable and uh it's painful to
watch but it's the right thing that he's
gone he called it eccentric for the
party to kick him out there wasn't much
thanks from him to the conservative
party for what they've done
was there any twing of twinge of guilt
any twinge of uh regrets when you watch
that speed when I made that decision to
resign as a parliamentary private
secretary which I appreciate is at the
very bottom of the uh the ladder in
terms of ministerial roles uh I I knew
that once I made that decision that it
was the right decision I haven't
regretted it once I'm just sad that it
came to this because I think he is as I
say a good person instinctively and I
think that he could have been and should
have been a great prime minister but
sadly just some poor choices uh over too
long a time they just meant that his
position was untenable there is a very
big live argument going on at the moment
about whether or not Boris Johnson
should be allowed to continue under the
timetable that he wants which is
possibly some weeks if not months until
the next conservative party leader and
hence prime minister is chosen now that
could be September or October do you
think Boris Johnson should stay in
Downing Street until then my personal
preference would have been because of
especially the last 24 hours in the
scene you've seen since then the Boris
would have gone entirely and we would
have installed Dominic Raab as an
interim prime minister and then with the
interim cabinet until we had a new
leader however I trusted the Graham
Brady to act on the behalf of Adventures
I trust the interim cabinet they're very
good people so Robert Buckland who I
don't believe would have gone in there
had they not known that they feel that
they would be making sure that there
were firm checks and balances on Boris
whilst he continues obviously as you say
until we elect a new leader so if that's
what the senior members of the party
have felt that they can live with and
the government will most importantly
function and continue to deliver
especially for the people that I'm proud
to represent than I can live with that
do you think that's the settle with the
conservative party as far as it's
possible to judge because we've only had
their speech in a few minutes do you
think colleagues will accept that
timetable or as you say given the event
to the last 36 48 hours do you think
that there will continue to be a debate
on that matter there probably will be a
small debate on that matter but I think
we have to just bring a closure we don't
need to keep having browse internally we
now need to focus on making sure that we
get a timetable in place to elect a new
leader that new leader get installed as
soon as possible with their cabinet and
that we then get most importantly back
on top of delivering for the people and
focusing on the big issues of the day
it's got a wide-ranging cabinet from
different wings of the party clearly to
Steward through this difficult time but
do you think there should be limits on
what the government over the next few
weeks and months while Boris Johnson is
still there effectively As a caretaker
should be able to do can Boris Johnson
make some of the decisions he would have
made anyway or should he just try and
run a steady a low profile as
unambitious uh a ship as possible
because those will be matters for the
next prime minister the Prime Minister
as we still is Boris Johnson was elected
on a conservative Manifesto we should be
delivering that Manifesto so anything
within that absolutely we should be
focusing on and also internationally we
can't suddenly stop helping our friends
in Ukraine the northern protocol is
something they're clearly needs solving
and the Boris and the cabinet agree to
so with issues like that we should be
absolutely going hell for leather on but
there are there is a baiting number 10
about whether or not to push the button
on a packet of tax carts changing
economic direction are those the kind of
decisions you want to see with Boris
Johnson still in charge I trust that the
cabinet as it now is will come around
the table look at the situation we have
a global crisis when it comes to
inflation we're seeing energy bills
Rising constituents in my area are
clearly worried particularly about
October if it looks like we need to take
action sooner rather than later then as
I'll be supportive of any action needs
to be taken to protect households with
their incomes but also with the rising
cost of food and energy what if there
are big issues like the Northern Ireland
protocol that could be up for debate in
the leadership contest do you think that
the party should just press on with that
bill despite the international hire
difficult conversations Europe not
really responding because they see a
change of leadership in Britain on the
way how can you deal with those kind of
situations with a caretaker prime
minister maybe for two months well the
northern protocol if I remember
correctly Sam you may correct me didn't
have any conservative member upon vote
against it there was a large amount of
support for it and and therefore I feel
that the Prime Minister and the cabinet
have a mandate from the conservative
party about benches to crack on with
those issues thank you very much indeed
clearly difficult day for Tory MPS but
there no regrets whatsoever from one
person who has called for Boris Johnson
he's called for Boris Johnson to send
out
I've seen her stuff that Sam and
certainly from some of the people that
Sam has been speaking to and MPS more
generally as well it does feel as though
not everyone is convinced that Boris
Johnson has bought himself enough time
to continue until the Autumn a couple of
tweets I just want to bring you uh now
from two people who we are potentially
expecting to throw their hat into the
ring for a leadership contest uh firstly
Tom tug and hat saying it's the right
call by Boris Johnson to resign he
delivered brexit rolled out the vaccine
and led on Ukraine now we need a clean
start well let's contrast that to Liz
trust shall we the foreign secretary the
Prime Minister has made the right
decision she says the government under
boris's leadership had many achievements
delivering brexit vaccines and backing
Ukraine she then says we need calmness
and unity now and to keep governing
while a new leader is found well let's
bring in our political Beth Rigby at
shall we and Beth it does feel doesn't
it like the starter gun has already been
found inspired the Jocelyn has done says
yeah I mean look the starting gun uh was
fired so weeks ago actually this has
been going on for weeks uh MPS trying to
Corral a support taking soundings from
back benches to see who might be in
their camp but now these leadership bids
that we've all been talking about are
behind the scenes are going to come out
into the open and as you were saying uh
Liz truss she will clearly try and run
Tom tug and heart has been an adversary
of Boris Johnson and arguably many many
MPS would have said Tom tookenheart was
someone that should have been in
government if not even in cabinet but he
was never given a job by Boris Johnson
and he was consigned to the back benches
where he became the chair of the Foreign
Affairs select committee made a very
powerful intervention during the
evacuation of Kabul and Afghanistan very
that was kind of the moment he kind of
Hit the Consciousness really in this
very powerful statement he made in the
comments and he is uh the guy that the
one nation group of of Tories the the
people that would say they're sort of
liberal conservatives to the to the left
of the party
um they are I think he's the guy that
would like to be their candidate so
we've got Liz trust Tom Tucker can't
swallow bravens or he said she wants to
Sajid Javit almost certainly will Rishi
and Ben Wallace the defense secretary
who has long been a supporter of
um I've just sorry I'm trying to get
this up for you uh has long been a key
supporter of Boris Johnson he actually
according some yougov polling that I'm
just trying to find out on my phone I
can't find it it's a new gov polling out
early in States then you have 716
conservative party members but he was
the favorite and then there would in in
from their point of view he was the
favorite followed by sunak and in a
runoff between them this is 716 members
but if you later out uh Ben Wallace was
Ben Wallace was was going to be crowned
uh the next leader so we've got got uh
we've got a series of Runners and Riders
now
it feels like their reaction to what's
happening boys Johnson is going to be
potentially critical are those who have
been loyal like Ben Wallace as you said
who haven't resigned a long-standing
Ally or the more critical people such as
saja jabid who of course was the first
one out of the blocks to quit I guess
it'll be interesting to see who ends up
being rewarded for the different
strategies
in the leadership contest to go by the
party yes
and potentially by uh if they make the
runoff as well by the way well I guess
look I get you know in terms of who gets
rewarded or punished I mean Boris
Johnson doesn't really have much support
on the back benches so I'm not sure that
that's going to be a particular
consideration uh for MPS what they will
be looking at is what's the base and
what can they do I mean it is true that
one former senior cabinet minister said
to me a couple of days ago that he
thought Nadine zahawi so I'm just the
doors opener
team Sahari was finished for standing on
those James Dodgers are you disappointed
to see him go James Doddridge
of course gave that very supportive
interview didn't he yesterday it's a
rough day for him James Doddridge is the
prime minister's ministerial Aid so he's
the guy that is the eyes and ears for
the Prime Minister uh in the Commons and
he must have had a really tough uh 24
hours but but yeah going back to going
back to MPS I mean different people took
different decisions so Liz trust decided
to remain outwardly loyal while she was
frenetically behind the scenes trying to
to get to get support
um Sajid Javid thought his best bet
would be to show leadership and
integrity he got kind of out of the
blocks by being in the Commons yesterday
and being able to make that uh
resignation speech but also have his
moment in the sun where the public got
to hear and party members his backstory
and his kind of pitch for the leadership
I am a man of integrity I didn't get
into politics to be somebody I came into
politics to do something
um so so then all be now uh get it
getting
um soundings from MPS working out what
their support base is and I imagine very
soon we will see uh those bids come out
it's been interesting today because you
know we're obviously talking uh to
people to see if they might come on
camera or will they make a statement and
I think maybe today a number of people
will think this is the moment of Boris
Johnson's resignation they don't want to
be seen to be too eager to be dancing on
his grave it's a bad analogy but you
know what I mean so they might just hold
off but don't make no mistake that the
Sounders we've taken this truss is
flying back right now she's on the plane
flying back because she needs to get
back here I guess it's the balance isn't
it between not wanting to as you put it
dance on his grave but also not being
too slow to uh to behind exactly and
thank you so much for the analysis uh
Beth Rigby their you are of course
watching sky we have just heard from the
Prime Minister giving his resignation
statement here in Downing streets
more to come
good afternoon you are watching at Sky
News at one we're live from Downing
streets
Boris Johnson resigns as prime minister
saying it was painful not to be able to
see out his term
I want you to know how sad I am to be
giving up the best job in the world
but then's the breaks
his wife Carrie carrying their baby
stood watching as he said that in
politics no one is remotely
indispensable
Mr Johnson promised that government
would carry on and he would continue as
prime minister until a new leader is
elected
[Music]
good afternoon this is Guy news at one
we are live in Downing Street where
Boris Johnson has just resigned telling
the country he finds it painful not to
see his term through well after an
unprecedented 48-hour power struggle
with his own MPS the Prime Minister
walked out of that door behind me saying
he fought so long to stay at number 10
because in his words it was his job his
duty and his obligation but in his own
words also at a mission that no one in
politics is remotely indispensable well
let's now listen to his statements in
full
it is clearly now the will of the
Parliamentary conservative party that
there should be a new leader of that
party and therefore a new prime minister
and I've agreed with sir Graham Brady
the chairman of our back bench MPS that
the process of choosing that new leader
should begin now and the timetable will
be announced next week and I've today
appointed a cabinet to serve as I will
until a new leader is in place
so I want to say to the millions of
people who voted for us in 2019 many of
them voting conservative for the first
time thank you for that incredible
mandate the biggest conservative
majority since 1987 the biggest share of
the vote since 1979.
and the reason I have fought so hard in
the last few days to continue to deliver
that mandate in person was not just
because I wanted to do so but because I
felt it was my job
my duty my obligation to you to continue
to do what we promised in 2019
and of course I'm immensely proud of the
achievements of this government from
getting brexit done to settling our
relations with the continent for over
half a century reclaiming the power for
this country to make its own laws in
Parliament getting us all through the
pandemic delivering the fastest vaccine
rollout in Europe the fastest exit from
Lockdown and in the last few months
leading the West in standing up to
Putin's aggression in Ukraine
and let me say no to the people of
Ukraine that I know that we in the UK
will continue to back your fight for
freedom for as long as it takes and at
the same time in this country we've been
pushing forward a vast program of
investment in infrastructure and skills
and Technology the biggest in a century
because if I have one insight into human
beings it is the genius and talent and
enthusiasm and Imagination are evenly
distributed throughout the population
but opportunity is not and that's why we
must keep leveling up keep unleashing
the potential of every part of the
United Kingdom and if we can do that in
this country we will be the most
prosperous in Europe
and in the last few days I've tried to
persuade my colleagues that it would be
eccentric to change governments when
we're delivering so much and when we
have such a vast mandate and when we're
actually only a handful of points behind
in the polls even in midterm after quite
a few months of pretty Relentless
sledging and when
the economic scene is so difficult
domestically and internationally and I
regret and not to have been successful
in those arguments and of course it's
painful and not to be able to see
through so many ideas and projects
myself but as we've seen at Westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves and my friends in
politics no one is remotely
indispensable and our brilliant and
darwinian system will produce another
leader equally committed to taking this
country forward through tough times not
just helping families to get through it
but changing and improving the way we do
things cutting burdens on businesses and
families and yes cutting taxes because
that is the way to generate the growth
and the income we need to pay for great
Public Services
and to that new leader I say whoever he
or she may be I say I will give you as
much support as I can
and to you the British public
I know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and uh perhaps quite a few who will also
be disappointed
and I want you to know how sad I am to
be giving up the best job in the world
that thems the breaks
I want to thank Carrie and our children
to all members of my family who've had
to put up with so much for so long I
want to thank the Peerless British civil
service for all the help and support
that you have given our police our
emergency services and of course our
fantastic NHS who at critical moment
helped to extend my own period in office
as well as our armed services and our
agencies that are so admired around the
world
and are infatuable conservative party
members and supporters whose selfless
campaigning makes our democracy possible
I want to thank the wonderful staff here
at Checkers uh to hear number 10 and of
course at Checkers and our fantastic
prop Force detectives the one group by
the way who never leak
above all I want to thank
you the British public
for the immense privilege that you have
given me
and I want you to know that from now on
until the new prime minister is in place
your interests will be served
and the government of the country
will be carried on
being prime minister
is an education in itself
I've traveled to every part of the
United Kingdom and in addition to the
beauty of our natural world I found so
many people possessed of such boundless
British originality and so willing to
tackle old problems in new ways that I
know that even if things can sometimes
seem dark now
our future together is golden
thank you all very much
thank you
well that was Boris Johnson's speech in
Downing Street it was listened to there
you can see by a crowd including his
wife Carrie Johnson and their
nine-month-old baby she was standing
next to Nadine dory's the culture
secretary long-standing friend and Ally
of the Prime Minister just behind them
you can see to the chief whip at Chris
Heaton Harris as someone who's had an
extremely fraught few days but there you
can see Carrie Johnson looking on as
Boris Johnson her husband gave his
resignation speech no sign of a toddler
and perhaps understandably anyone with
small children will know
at the other end of Downey Street they
were very different scenes I think we
could have a quick look there you can
see people clouding around trying to
capture a moment of history on their
mobile phones
people smiling we don't know if they
were supporters of the Prime Minister or
perhaps people who were glad to see
well these guys there chanting out out I
think no uh question where their
politics were but certainly a crowded
entry to Downing Street there as people
came to watch Boris Johnson give at that
historic speech
but we can bring in our political as a
Beth Rigby who's been with us here
throughout the morning and Beth it was
quite a defined speech from the Prime
Minister as well wasn't it going through
his greatest achievements and clearly as
well this morning making those final
appointments to his cabinet too yeah
look I think when you kind of I'm just
kind of going back through what he said
and as I said earlier it was vintage
Boris Johnson he put on his best show uh
today but he also made clear in that
speech that he wasn't a reluctant
resigner sorry he was he wasn't yeah he
was a reluctant resigner he started off
by saying thank you for the incredible
mandate the biggest conservative
majority since 1987 and he said the
reason I fought so hard in the last few
days to continue to deliver that mandate
in Parson was not just because I wanted
to do so because I felt it was my job my
duty my obligation to you to continue to
do what we promised in 2019 so prime
minister forced out but clearly thinking
he still had the Mandate from the public
and he
of his decision said it's clearly now
the will of the Parliamentary
conservative party that there should be
new leader and therefore a new prime
minister he then went on to say this was
one of the you know he has a brilliant
way with words Boris Johnson he was a
columnist I mean lots of his words I
should also have have been very
controversial and he has been held to
account for some of the phrases he's
used but but in this instance he used
this phrase he said hard instinct is
powerful and when the herd moves it
moves and it did move didn't it it moved
with ferocious Pace a stampede of
resignations from Tuesday night into
Wednesday morning with now 59
resignations from government and then he
said no one in politics is in politics
no one is remotely dispensable
um
he also said uh and again a message to
the Parliamentary party uh that he
wasn't really doing as bad as perhaps
they thought pointing out that the
Tories were only a handful of points
behind in the polls even in midterm I
mean I I'd seen them in double digits at
points um division so I you know a
handful of points that might be a bit
contested
um but he said after quite a few months
with pretty Relentless Legend that's not
bad going when the economic scene is so
difficult domestically and
internationally so he uh very clear
there that maybe things from his
perspective were not as bad as perhaps
some of his uh cabinet and party uh
would have thought but he said and and
this one really stood Stout for me I
want you to know how sad I am to be
giving up the best job in the world but
thems the brakes and he said he then
ended didn't he by thank Kim the British
public for the privilege of having the
job and he said even in these dark days
our future remains golden so a flick of
Boris boosterism and optimism at the end
and then and then Rapture us Applause
from the MPS that had come to watch the
speech and as you said uh behind us
there outside number 11 all of his staff
and Carrie Johnson his wife and his baby
uh Romy and their little son wealth not
there but as you said and we both know
because we've both got kids you don't
bring toddlers out to official occasions
like this feels like that was a very
legitimate and sensible decision indeed
the kind of newborn and the sling is one
thing or the nine month old I should say
in the sling is one thing Beth thank you
very much for your analysis as always
Beth Rigby political editor there she
was talking about the rapturous Applause
in the streets from Boris Johnson's
allies who were his staff but also the
friendly MPS who came to watch too I
guess the question now is what will the
reception be among the wider
parliamentary part vast majority of him
did not come to the streets in Downing
Street will they accept his desire to
stay on as leader until the Autumn will
they try and push him out it feels like
these questions still to be answered now
despite his resignation Boris Johnson
has still been making appointments to
his cabinet this morning to try and fill
the posts that have been left vacant by
all those resignations so let's have a
little run through shall we number 10
announced that Greg Clark has been
appointed as Secretary of State for
leveling up housing and communities now
that is the role that Michael Gove was
sat from last night James cleverley has
been appointed as the new secretary of
state for Education the role that became
available after Michelle dobland quits